Hello everybody, hi!
Hi hi!
Hi everybody!
Hello!
Hi, long time no seeish.
Feels like it though.
Hello!
Whick!
Thought I'd never see those wiggles again.
Thank you for the good thing!
Hello, Bito and I was like, you were, I'm Mr. Bito.
Hello, hi.
It still feels...
Strange for me.
I still don't quite feel in my element.
Even though it's my PC.
It still feels weird.
But hello.
Hello.
We missed you.
We don't.
I missed you guys.
I missed you so much.
Oh, wait.
I just realized.
I got, like, a new chat, but it's, like, kind of frozen.
I tried something else.
because I was...
Oh, it's just really slow.
Hi.
Got a new CSS.
Not CSS.
I tried something else because I was like, oh, you know,
it's always freezing.
So I tried something else.
But it doesn't seem to be working either.
Opti!
Happy birthday!
the way.
Wait one second.
Thank you so much.
I missed you guys.
84 years.
I had a new personal best while bouldering today.
So I'm still riding high.
Is it too late to submit a lizard?
No!
Because I haven't had a chance to put on the lizards.
So please.
It's mainly because I have been doing everything but being
on my computer lately.
so i am always collecting lizards i went to a birthday party
on friday it was kind of weird but they had pizza and a very
cute mouse was singing wow a pizza party pizza birthday
party on a friday that's like the luckiest thing ever
actually i planned that because i was like man i probably
missed so many birthdays you know i'm gonna keep chat as it
is i don't think there's anything I can do to fix it at
least it shall not it should not freeze it's just slow so
sorry so sorry it will not freeze it's just slow slow slow
slow slow but yeah my move has been going good I oh I feel
I'm starting to feel really good about this um what else can
i say that i cannot say i have air i am not sweltering in
the heat feels good she doesn't want to fix us it's over you
don't need fixing that's why haza
yeah i am air conditioned i am no spiders well actually
funny you mentioned that because the first day i got here i
mean the cafe's abandoned right so like there's gonna be
some cobwebs there's gonna be some something or other but i
i was i was i don't even remember what i was doing i think i
was just like cleaning up a little bit making the cafe
presentable when i see this
humongous the largest spider crawl out from under a door and
it's like that's how I imagine its legs sound and it was
like and then it stops and then it goes and it looks at me
and I'm looking at him and I'm like hey buddy I know this
place hasn't had anybody in it for a long time but
you you you he just stood there it was like he was more like
he was more like he was more like and I was like I know more
Mr. Nice Ghost so my roommate was greeting you I had another
spider that I was like okay you know what we got rid of this
this this guy I didn't I didn't kill him, by the way.
I put him out.
I set him free.
I set him free outside.
But I had another spider.
And I was like, you know what?
You are up in the corner.
I will leave you alone.
You leave me alone.
I'll leave you alone.
Okay.
I updated the retro rewind wise.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, though.
Thank you so much.
next time we play.
Looking forward to it.
But, uh...
But...
They will pay rent by eating mosquitoes.
Exactly!
But...
So then I was like, I'll keep this other guy.
And then...
He decided, I'm gonna move to another corner.
And I was like, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You have your designated corner of the cafe.
You're not allowed to walk around willy-nilly, right?
And then another corner.
And I was like, whoa, and then I see him making a nest from
corner.
This is a separate.
This is a, we're on a third and a fourth corner.
He is making a nest from corner to corner.
I'm watching him literally do it.
And I'm like, excuse me.
What am I to you?
The greed, absolutely.
And then I see him in my shower.
And I say, nobody, you gotta go, you gotta...
It's...
You're fired!
Get out!
I don't need you!
Graco, thank you for the pink.
I will be careful to not swallow the spiders while sleeping.
Thank you.
Mito, could you spare a karaoke tip?
Oh geez, I could try.
At this new bar, I can't seem to hear myself off key until
hearing it recorded.
I've never had this problem before.
Can you properly hear yourself?
Because if I can't hear myself while I'm singing, it's kind
of like similar where like, you know, singers will have like
monitors in their ears.
Usually that's like a, if it's a big stadium or whatever.
But if I can't hear myself, I think I'm, I think I would be
tone, not tone deaf, but I think I would be off key also.
Yeah, maybe, yeah, trying like to squeeze, not squeeze.
Press your ear down.
Plug up your one ear or something.
I was saying off key, it's fine.
Wait, it's actually really difficult to sing off key if
you...
Oh my gosh, guys.
I'm just like so talented.
Like, it's so hard to sing poorly.
No, that's just an octave lower.
I'm trying to sing Chandelier.
No, that's just high.
That's just me shouting.
I want to swing from the chandelier from the chandelier
Wow, thank you so much for all the super chats you guys
paying my rent to the mint thing for 25 bucks I just imagine
a gorilla because of your because of your name I'll just
imagine a gorilla being like scratchy scratch scratch in my
armpit typing in a super chat like you know how gorilla are
so funny.
They're like, monkeys don't know how funny they are.
Do you know what I mean?
Like, they'll just kind of be like, oh gosh, I can't show
you.
I'm just, I'm a PNG.
But they'll like, just kind of like scratch themselves and
be like, type, type, type.
Do you know what I mean?
Lucky spider, I mean, yeah, what a creep.
Anyone, anyone check and see if we're missing a spider?
One freaky mermaid cafe limit.
Get that spider out of there.
Yeah, he's gone.
He's gone.
Hey, Amito, have you heard about the Over the Garden Wall
concert?
I have!
I did.
I got a TikTok about it.
And I have to travel a little bit for one, but I can...
I'm going to try and go.
Oh my gosh, my first ever Over the Garden Wall concert.
I might cry.
Yeah, if I can get a ticket.
If I can get a ticket.
I haven't tried yet.
Don't leave clothes on the ground.
Spiders are into fashion too, but they don't like...
wearing the same outfit i'm scared though that the spider's
gonna wear my clothes and then i'll walk out and i'll be
like someone has to change or no what if he comes out and
he's like one of us has to change and it's me it's me it's
always me how's the pc for the most part my pc seems okay
yesterday i was having some weird lagging issues and then
okay can you guys be reddit for me for I'm having an issue
Where my second monitor When my computer goes to sleep Or
rather when my monitors turn off My second When I wake it
back up When I wake it back up My second monitor does not
turn on And I Tried searching Reddit And everybody seems to
have 5 billion different solutions tips for the world new
nvidia driver tries to fix that i don't use nvidia okay have
an upvote yippee my first upvote you're the asshole everyone
sucks here not the asshole divorce him this is too realistic
wait this is too much wait what subreddit did i post on
Wait, hold on.
Okay, please answer my question.
I'm trying to post on R slash help me, Minto.
A place where only I can ask questions.
Did you plug into the same G?
You know what?
I think I took a picture of my...
I don't know where my phone is.
R slash help Minto.
there's no help for you wait where did i post r slash girl
dinner uh-huh i can't i can't do this anymore power cycle
the monitor unplug the power cable for five or so seconds
and back in okay i will try thank you reddit i'm actually
the problem is between the keyboard and the chair tips for
dorm and i'm all i'm all i die you should look closer at the
profile picture and pay attention to the head of the body
okay i'm guessing it's the head of a pug like a doll the dog
but it's so tiny it's so small
i low-key kind of love the girl dinner subreddit i know they
really do have crazy stories on them turned off and leave it
off and you'll know why it doesn't work no not my post
history no you'll see me on mmm our slash wonder bread no
hey I figured it out posted 10 years ago if it works it
works if it fits I sit our slash minto dinner tonight I
think I'll have a spaghetti mmm I didn't I haven't been
eating so much lately i wonder if i'm okay no i think it's
just i don't know it's been a lot going on and such maybe a
stress scratch scratch oh bicky cute by that super thank you
I can't wait to see you perform at SmashCon!
Unfortunately I didn't win the meet and greet, but the
Ectoplasm perfume will be there in spirit.
No!
Jay!
You have to tell them.
You have to say it's very important.
What?
No!
No.
But I'll see you at the panel, right?
And stuff I hope.
Yeah, I will be in Australia.
in like two weeks.
Good.
You're a growing girl.
You need sustenance, Minky.
I'll try.
Glad your move is finally done.
I'm moving several states over in a week, so I'm not around
as much.
That's what I'm doing.
Good luck, Road.
You're just like me.
Baby Cor, thank you so much for the fun.
Get this.
You're just like me.
I, uh...
Yeah.
I feel like the move is not quite over until you have every
box unboxed, right?
Right now, I'm trying to... Most of my stuff came unscathed.
That's just a few things.
Oh gosh, you guys, I'm so sad.
My first ever fan.
The first ever thing that I crowdfunded on my channel was a
Dyson fan because I wanted it really quiet for my closet and
it did not break but it got mega scuffed and I'm so so sad
mmm thank you so much for that mr.
we don't imagine this the year is three three thousand three
hundred and twelve humans have expanded and colonized You've
amassed billions of fans and already have a ship called
Minto Sands Frontiers and are building a Dadaqahedron-shaped
spaceship for the Ibous.
What would you name it?
The big space.
Maybe.
The Ibous space.
The boo space?
It's probably from stress and lack of schedule.
eating super important to have energy to handle stress so
please make sure to eat thank you dorko dorko i'm sorry i
missed your birthday too happy birthday big space in space
yeah
the big space
but yeah i
i feel i feel really good here i it is very strange i do
feel like probably part of me is uh Is, uh, I don't know,
every time I change time zones, I cannot eat for like, or
rather my, my stomach goes haywire for like weeks after.
Is anybody else the same?
Anybody else the same?
Woo, Jay!
Thank you so much for your 25 bucks.
Your birthday merch recently came in.
Thank you, Liquid Toast.
Thanks for getting it.
Can't wait to get this shirt hot and sweaty at the gym.
Ha, yeah!
You used to be that way, really.
Do you kind of miss your old place?
Also, how are your ears?
Thanks for checking in on my ears.
I can't say I miss my old place so much.
I really, really like this place, so I'm very, very happy.
Very, very happy that I got so lucky.
I got, I remember when I was showing people pictures, and I
was like, look at this.
And then, and then I would tell them the price.
And they were like, what?
I got a mega good deal, you guys.
It is a little more expensive for rent than my previous.
Just a little, though.
And for the location and for the everything that I need, it
must be haunted by me.
Did someone die in there?
My hopes and my dreams?
Good luck.
After a little research, it could be faulty display port.
You could also reset graphics driver by pressing control.
Sinister, thank you.
Thank you so much for your...
That's really helpful.
Thank you.
Though, to be fair, I had so much that I needed to do that I
just like threw every cable together.
So there might be some things that I did not plug in
properly that I have to re-plug in.
I haven't done any cable management, nothing, nothing.
like i currently have the the i currently have the uh power
cable for my for my left monitor like between my legs
because i was just like throw it all in record what i need
to record and i'll fix it later no worries on the birthday
thank you so much party friday was great for me and all of
us yeah I hope everybody whose birthdays I missed.
Hope you have enjoyed Friday.
The scuff adds character and shows the passage of time.
A reminder of a milestone and a marker of the year since the
beginning.
Wait, that's so deep.
I'm five years old and this is deep.
I'm moving really soon, too.
Ben, I was going to take the train all the way across the
country.
Putting all my junk in my truck.
Dang.
Unreal Citizen, thank you for moving cars.
No!
Thank you very much, though.
But it's okay.
Because everybody has always been so generous and so, you
know, everything.
I am so okay.
But thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Mintos should switch from Windows to Linux Mint.
If I could figure out Linux Mint, I wonder if it's okay for
streaming.
I've always wondered, though, like, is it where it's, like,
Games run easily on Linux and everything.
Hope your figures in Dojinchi are okay.
So far, I've only discovered one scuff on a figure.
Could be yours.
And so far, my Dojinchi are mostly okay.
I've had a few casualties because the way I moved my stuff
was like I put it all into a crate and then had it shipped
over from my old cafe.
And that crate must have been so stinking.
hot that some things in there like if i had text printed on
a piece of paper some of it melted to like other things and
then like transferred the paper or transferred the ink to
the other thing so i'm gonna try and get some like alcohol
and get little baby no just kidding and and like some
isopropyl alcohol and see if that'll get it off or something
get turked yeah i'm gonna get i'm gonna drown my sadness and
alcohol no but i've taken out a couple of figures and they
seem good they seem good so white girl worst i play all my
games on linux it's super easy the only issue is if you want
to play anything that uses anti-cheat software okay i don't
play very many pvp shooter things so i've been running a
version of Linux for over a year, it runs most games great.
You can also keep a Windows partition and use it if you need
to.
Because my computer right now is Windows 10.
I have not to upgrade it to Windows 11.
And then on my potato PC, it was Windows 11, and I
downgraded it to Windows 10.
So, kind of wondering recently what to do.
I also received the birthday merch last week.
I can't stop hugging the food roll.
And having her stare at me for a thing at the the live
theater now i will thank you
but uh i don't know maybe maybe uh linux minto will come to
you coming to a theater near you speaking of which i want to
go see obsession do you guys know when it leaves theaters i
was like maybe i can go this week i'm trying to like stop
myself from just constantly constantly unpacking
I tomorrow no way no way it's coming to streaming tomorrow
no way wait can we do a watch along then it'll be on
streaming this week wait like I said I'm trying to just stop
myself from constant unpacking and so I was like maybe I'd
take a break and go to a movies
apparently it was made by another youtuber yes it was I'm
getting the guys both the back rooms and obsession were both
made by youtubers and i'm getting them mixed up i think the
back rooms guy was made by the guy that not posted it
originally the story but like he made a backroom series on
youtube if i'm not mistaken and then the other guy the other
guy uh was like a comedian and did like little sketches on
youtube
wick oh no wait alan wick sounds right am i crazy
backrooms cane pixels obsession curry baker i think i think
oh thank you thank you
but maybe we should just do a watch along done windows 11
takes snapshot of your desktop all the time for a recall
feature i've heard about that i've heard about that and
that's Basically why I have enough to change it.
Steam has done a lot to help Linux gaming because Steam
machines use Linux.
Did you guys hear that...
That Valve is releasing the Steam OS?
So that if you can't get the Steam machine, I guess you can
just put the Steam OS on your computer?
I wonder how that will be.
Hmm.
That's why I leave...
Goatsy out for the Windows people.
They have a rotation of people and they're like, all right,
who has to go to that guy's computer today?
When are they releasing Mintois?
I don't know.
That's ransomware, probably.
I'm curious about it, though.
If anybody tries it, report back.
Report back.
The Steam machine is not Valve's goal.
The Steam OS is...
That's what I think, too.
Gabe Newell was once a Microsoft guy.
Wait, was it really?
I didn't know that.
I will only use the term Gabe Cube.
The Gabe Cube?
You got games on your Gabe Cube?
I'm in Phantom.
It was my birthday on Saturday.
Party!
Just want to thank you for being such a positive constant in
my life.
I'd love a watch along for it, even if it's pretty shocking.
Buddy!
Thank you for the Super Tie.
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
Gosh, this is BGM for this is like such a...
I could like, it's such a good Zatu music.
But we will be playing...
Dave the Diver DLC.
Jungle, jungle DLC.
I completed Dave the Diver.
Unfortunately though, I beat it off-stream.
She plays games off-stream?
How could she?
But...
I forgot there's a game on-stream.
You're pretty cute, you know that?
Bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga-bouga.
How did Minto beat a game without our help?
I know.
Crazy.
Absol- lunacy.
I heard the recently that Dave the Dave and Dave the Diver
is based off of a real person.
Is this true?
I heard that
he is.
Apparently apparently he is he is based off of a real diver
named Dave that was like yeah he was a hero He was!
He was!
It's actually a very sad story, but like, he is so awesome.
So, Dave Shaw, is that what his name was?
I couldn't remember his last name, but if that's it, thank
you.
Basically, he was like a really, really good diver.
And his last dive was him searching for some...
Another diver that unfortunately went through a pretty tough
passage and unfortunately lost his life in there.
But because it was so difficult to get in there itself,
nobody could retrieve his body.
And so Dave went in and found him, but experienced some
complications himself.
uh the last but the last thing he did was he clipped the
guy's body to himself and then like you know what like when
you can release the oxygen that sends you to the top or
whatever he did that so that both of them floated to the top
he didn't just he didn't just do it for himself he got both
of them a real hero yeah it's actually like i'm probably
terribly but read about it is really really fascinating
yeah oh seven for dave and so it made me think and then with
the dlc coming i was like man i kind of really want to play
dave the diver again yeah dave oh gosh diving and cave cave
spelunking you will never catch me maybe diving in like an
open ocean.
Right?
And then I'm going to go to the very bottom.
And then I'm going to come up real fast and I'm going to
drink some beer.
And I'm going to say beer o'clock, baby.
But cave diving, you'll never find me in there.
You'll know.
Do you have a chance to try the Dredge DLC?
Like the Dave the Diver Dredge DLC?
I don't think so.
Actually, This is my first Dave DLC.
I didn't try the...
I should have tried the Godzilla one.
But, yeah.
I feel like I've seen that happen before.
No consequences for sure.
None.
Gosh, I can't wait for more...
For more.
Well, no.
Wait, the new Until Dawn game is not another super massive
game, is it?
Did they, like, sell the rights to that?
Dark Pictures.
Yeah.
It's a different thing.
Sony owned the franchise.
That's why we got that Freco movie, huh?
Got another team to make it.
I hope it's just as goofy and dumb.
I'm excited, though.
I heard about the Until Dawn movie.
And it's literally Until Dawn with...
In Just Name.
I am curious what they'll do with the next one, though.
with this until dawn too excited though i still think my
favorite is man and madame because i think the man and
madame story itself is really fascinating movie is not like
the game not even a little bit
mint rocket did you make this here right copyright me thank
you dave the diver for giving me all the credit
I watched the Until Dawn movie on the plane.
It was horrendous.
You should watch it.
Horrendous in a good way?
Hmm, okay.
I don't think it translates well to a film.
The only...
No, I don't think so.
I think it does translate well to a film.
But they would...
Rather, I would want the thing that they did with the Clue
movie.
Where it has different endings of different people dying.
Like, I feel like if they make a movie of it, it feels like
too much of a canon end.
You know what I mean?
That would be big.
Yeah!
Gosh, if you guys haven't seen the Clue movie, it's so...
Yeah.
They should have kept the awkward silences during the
decision points.
Like, I think, you know, you could even include the totems
and things like that.
You know, the game is already a little paranormal and that
there's a Wendigo, so...
The one with Tim Curry?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
I watched an interview with Tim Curry somewhat recently.
It was like one of his few public appearances in recent
years.
Clue movie, like the board game Clue.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
yeah the guy is super sick he's not in good health but he i
think he had a like a pretty bad stroke in the library i'm
pretty sure i think that was it yeah but he was still in
such good spirits he still is so witty you know yeah it's a
good it's a good interview i feel like murder mystery movies
have you seen the knives out franchise the first one is my
favorite mystery movie ever.
No way, way to have him.
Knives, arrow.
Wait, I'm gonna look it up.
Oh, sorry, I clicked out of the game.
Well, oh, wait, I haven't seen it, but I've seen this
before.
They're so posh.
Thank you for the recommendation.
Tim Curry talked about how Miss Piggy was his one great love
affair.
Star-studded cast.
Oh, yeah.
They're funny, too.
Oh, really?
Watch out for spoilers.
Okay.
Yeah, Tim Curry did voice Auntie Whispers in Over the Garden
Wall.
We will, once again, watch Over the Garden Wall this
Halloween.
Oh, it's...
Wow, this is going to be crazy, though.
It's going to feel so different for me watching it in a new
location.
Wow.
whole series is tongue-in-cheek oh fun fun fun fun I got my
rainbow eye rainbow eye blue badge of
course thank you I love over the garden walk
are you gonna do a world cup watch along probably not I've
seen lots of other people doing them And honestly, I know so
little about soccer, about football.
So I think you can enjoy it probably more with other people,
more so than me.
But it is pretty cool.
Yeah, yeah.
My city is so full of soccer fans.
Toki Berta's been unhinged with Canadian pride.
Yeah, Kiara, I saw that she...
sports places and stuff though you could keep asking us to
explain everything for you classic little sister experience
I don't even know what I would who I would root for I'd be
like oh these guys look good I don't know Tim Curry is such
a presence on screen he never was a big superstar but I
honestly can't think of anything that he anything he was in
that I didn't like charisma I would say I mean I would say
he's a superstar in his own right he's a he's a near
household name I'd say just root for both sides yeah Mexico
Mexico She had 80% Argentina viewers on that one, which was
fun since she was supporting Austria.
That's cute, though.
They were...
They were still watching with her.
It's fine.
I'm really enjoying watching everybody enjoying it.
You know what I mean?
Date idea.
Invade Kiara's watch along and make her explain everything.
Okay.
A date?
May I ask what about this game you recommend it for?
Dave the Diver?
It's pretty chill.
I like fishing.
And it's almost that.
Hmm.
It is wholesome.
But yeah, shall we actually play?
I think I need to do new game though, right?
Wait, no, wait.
Cancel, continue?
Wait.
What?
Continue?
Wait.
I think I...
You don't need a new game.
Oh.
Let's try it.
One year of loving me!
Come on, let's try!
Okay.
I think this is the DLC.
Did you happen to hear that loud noise last night?
Yeah, we heard a loud rumbling from far over.
A researcher was out investigating that area.
And she contacted me saying something strange happened.
I love the
du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
I love the Diver and Alamito.
Thank you.
Welcome back, Raccoon, and welcome back, Vionic Yifur.
Oh, I see.
Should you go check it out?
I suppose I should, but I'd like you folks to come along to.
Us too?
Yes, we need to investigate a little bit.
lake in the jungle and no one is better than you for
underwater exploration dave oh i see the blue hole's been
quiet lately and you've helped us a lot dr bichen i'd love
to go with you but i'm not sure if it's a good idea to leave
bancho running the shop alone mr minto mr two no need to
worry the researcher doesn't seem too fond of the local food
there so i was hoping bancho could come Oh, then we don't
have to worry about the shop.
Oh, here we go.
But would Boncho want to come along?
He seems pretty happy with things here.
Boncho needs to get out once in a while for some cooking
inspiration.
It'll be fun if we all go together.
Let's head to the shop and try to convince him.
Welcome to the jungle.
Go to Boncho.
Oh, geez.
Wait, I have to remember how to play this game.
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
To sushi.
Are you sitting on moving boxes right now?
No, I'm on my chair.
Wow, look at this.
Who the heck is this guy?
Though, the chair returns.
I, I, when they were moving my stuff, they were like, they
moved my PC.
And it was all wrapped up in foam and everything.
But the guy moved it and then like came back over to me and
was like, was that thing I just moved?
A PC?
And I was like, yeah, that's my computer.
And he was like, that thing was massive.
He was like, that was a beast.
And then they saw some of my other stuff.
One thing the guy was like is, he was like, beefy computer
yeah beefy computer he was like are you a fan of metal gear
solid I was like oh yeah I like that game and he was like oh
cool actually he was like actually I've been playing through
five and I was like oh wow somebody playing through five for
the first time in 2026.
I was like, wait, that's so awesome.
He did that.
But I was like, it was funny because he moved something.
The first thing he moved was into the moving truck, you
know?
And then he was like, are you a fan of...
Are you a fan of...
Metal Gear?
And I was like, oh yeah!
And then...
And then I would see another box that had a Metal Gear Solid
logo on it And then another box that had a Metal Gear Solid
logo on it And I was like, this guy probably thinks...
I'm obsessed!
I would be like...
I was like...
Every time another box would come out, I would be like, What
gave him that impression that I'm a fan?
I'm something of a boss myself.
Haha, yeah, I said the Metal Gear Ghost.
Today's my birthday.
A victory sure would be nice.
How we don't.
Thank you for being the silly ghost, babe.
We all love.
I hope you're doing well.
My place!
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, is it your birthday for real?
Or are you just quoting Ace Combat?
Don't look now, but your obsession is showing.
Yeah!
I was like really, I wasn't embarrassed, but I was like,
maybe I should have...
Maybe I should have changed the boxes.
The ladder tour apartment is such a thrill!
Yeah, I specifically requested the highest...
I requested a high... I got a high-rise apartment.
And I requested that I have a ladder installed.
So that I could...
So that I could climb every time.
No stairs, no elevator.
Ladder only.
Yeah, it was funny.
But at the same time I was like, I've been sweating.
What?
Metal Gear?
Never heard of it!
Those are my dogs!
Anyway, what's this all of a sudden?
We need to investigate a lake in the jungle.
I think we could really use your cooking skills.
All the things they could have seen in Metal Gear is
probably the low on the freaky scale.
That's true, that's true.
I've heard the food there is pretty terrible.
Mmm, ingredients from a new region do sound interesting.
But I'm not comfortable leaving my shop unattended.
I kind of wish I played MGS5 a bit later.
They really upgraded stuff about the game after I beat it.
I couldn't wait.
I had a lust for revenge.
Woohoo!
Are your dogs named Ocelot and steak?
No!
Work
it off.
stop this whole time.
You haven't even been able to enjoy our team's dinners since
you're always busy cooking.
A short trip to a new place might just be the change you
need.
Hmm, a lake means freshwater fish.
The blue hole only has saltwater fish.
So it's been a while since I've cooked freshwater dishes.
Alright, I'll come along.
Great decision.
I have decided, though, if I get another cat, I think I'll
get one at the end of the year.
After like a bulk of my traveling is done and stuff like
that.
So you may see another cat in the future.
And it's a long time though that I have to wait.
I'm sad.
Yeah.
I got a kitten that named her Minky recently.
Shut up, that's so cute.
Looking forward to more kitty pics.
Yeah.
But I'll have to see their personality before I name them
and everything, you know?
Nah, both cats.
I did not have any cats with me.
I'm lonely.
But at the same time, I'm constantly vacuuming.
Getting dust and...
I open up my boxes and like it just...
So I'm constantly vacuuming.
Yeah.
so i don't think they would like that very well
still not comfortable leaving the shop to someone else do
you think i should close it for a while yes it won't be for
long i'll let the staff take a break while we're away
everyone gets a trip luckios whenever he does that he sounds
like the things from from mortis faith like the demons in
faith that game.
Minky's a stinky cat.
No!
But they might be kind of stinky.
You'll probably need to wrap a few things up before we
leave.
Give me a call when you're ready.
Alright, nice.
Let's go to the jungle.
I need to talk to this guy though.
Let's head to the jungle!
Um, hello?
Uh, yeah.
Oh, it's just...
Barely believe you hired me.
The sushi's so good here?
You think I'm...
eat all your profits.
His name is Raptor.
James.
Woo-ha.
This place is 890 square meters.
So the optimal seating capacity is...
Never mind.
El Nino.
Ha-ha-ha.
Satisfy the customers with my signature movements.
It...
This is just the DLC portion of the game.
I did beat the game, but I can't remember.
Maybe I beat it on another Steam account, so it doesn't show
up.
But yeah.
Raptor and El Nino are my servers, too.
Also, it's not El Nino because it doesn't have the squiggle.
Yeah.
But yeah, so.
This is kind of just if you start the DLC.
How do I call him?
I guess I gotta...
Call him.
Dr. Bacon.
I'm ready!
Good, then let's head to my boat.
Off we go!
To a new place.
That's me!
That's what I just did.
Slaverless, Nino.
Nice cutscene.
Cinema.
Whoa.
Oh cute!
We got a new outfit!
Ah!
Damn it!
The fancy clothes and the diamond rings.
Diamond rings.
Who?
Huh.
Oh!
Save the diver in the jungle!
I mean it can't be that far if we're going by this boat
right?
Oh, that was sick.
Okay.
Sunday 11th.
Oh no, Sunday November 27th.
We finally made it.
That was way too far for a small boat.
Okay.
But I don't see any town around here.
Oog!
Pancho's been so seasick he hasn't been able to eat
properly!
Our guide should be here soon.
Let's wait a bit.
Guide?
Oh guide!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, the graphics!
Whoa!
Sick ride!
Hello?
Xenomic!
Thank you so much for the red!
Hello!
Our guide has arrived!
Go and talk to him.
Iggy.
Oh, we may have gotten a bit lost on the way, but hey, we
made it here.
Safe and sound!
You suddenly stopped at some weird island and had us stay
there forever too.
Exploring- wait, what?
He just abandoned us?
We're single choice!
Thank you for the fun!
Get there!
Ray back!
Thank you for the gift!
If you mean drinking five cans of beer and not even getting
started until the next afternoon.
Thank you.
From Faraba, thank you.
It's really hot that day.
Hello.
Are you the village guide by any chance?
I will take you for the bag you did.
Y'all must be the visitors from out of town.
You must be tired from that long ride.
Name's Rimbu.
Thank you, dog.
Nice to meet you, Rimboo.
I'm Dave.
Death vision, thank you.
Over there is my colleague.
Looks like y'all had yourselves a long day.
Let's save the introductions for the car.
Sounds good, ha-ha.
First noon, thank you.
Whoa, it just says Hyundai on it.
Wait.
What the heck?
Let me introduce myself again.
Name's Rimboo.
That's a fine name.
I'm Cobra, a businessman.
I'm breaking.
Got a message from my assistant in the village, so I came on
over.
I'm bad.
You folks sure are interesting.
The place you're heading to is called Uttara.
Uttara Khan.
You have a sponsor?
That's crazy.
It's an old village by a lake where the terrain keeps shift.
That sounds like the blue hole!
There's another place like that.
Well now.
But lately strange things have started happening.
I heard a dinosaur carcass washed up!
Great.
Around here, the lake meets the sea.
So unusual creatures do show up sometimes.
But a dinosaur though?
Never would have thought.
To think something like that still exists in our world.
My oh my!
Wait a second.
I had no idea.
I promise.
What about the villagers?
Would it be okay for outsiders like us to visit?
Well, there are quite a few ruins around the village.
So we do get outsiders now, man.
Because of that, some folks are friendly towards strangers,
while others tend to be more cautious.
Still, the village chief's a kind man, so y'all should be
fine staying for a while.
We're almost at the village.
The road goes uphill from here, so it might get a little
bumpy.
How are they talking to him?
Oh, I guess Dave is in the passenger seat, right?
Dinosaurs.
Dinosaurs in the jungle!
Oh my god.
Ace Combat 4 soundtrack will release digitally for the first
time will be likely published around June 30th.
Oh, that's so soon!
I need it.
Wow.
Monkey?
What is that?
that mickey mickey it's already evening welcome to utara
village the village is built pretty high up
mickey wow wow okay i want to get to dive in style utara con
village oh god there she was utara con the grandma a hundred
years old older more.
She is always lying about her age.
Nobody knows.
They just know she's ancient.
Is this our... Wait.
Is this the assistant friend?
Muna!
Oh, wow, she's cute.
Dr. Bacon, you actually made it!
How have you been?
Good to see you.
Wait.
I like her.
You said the guy is helping with the investigation.
I'm Muna.
I've been getting a lot of Spinosaurus compilation music
videos.
Spinosaurus is in such a strange spot, right?
Because they just can't figure out what this guy looks like.
He's going through.
He's always going through a change.
But we recently lost a dinosaur.
So sad.
I can't remember the name off the top of my head right now,
though.
Go after him, then.
I can't.
It's like Pluto.
What do you mean we lost it?
I believe it was found that...
Uh...
What was it?
Hold on.
I'm gonna look at it.
Wait, I don't have my phone!
I don't want to say the facts wrong, though.
Like, they thought he existed, but not actually.
If that makes sense.
Yeah, it wasn't a unique species.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
He was just 20.
They discovered him, like, not so long ago even.
1996, I think?
Uh, I think they misread parts of some other ones.
Yeah, yeah, that sounds right.
He's real to me.
What was it, though?
Uh, it was some form of Spinosaurus, though, no.
Not Spinosaurus, but you know what?
I mean that that that class whatever it's fine she used to
work as my assistant but she's been on something like a
sabbatical wasn't there something about you going into
hiding after a failed crypto investment I can't believe you
brought that Buddha Luna not the failed crypto investment
If you disappear without notice again, it won't be this easy
to get reinstated, Muna.
Now that I've made back my initial investment, I've got to
work hard, really hard.
Let's get to it then.
Where's that dinosaur carcass you mentioned?
Oh, you should probably check that out first.
Come this way.
Yes, please.
I want to see.
Oh!
Wait!
Huh?
That's one massive dinosaur!
Yeah, is that a mosasaur?
How on earth did it get here?
This is a freshwater lake.
Isn't it a marine species?
What is it?
Bottom of this lake is connected to the ocean.
The water forms layers due to differences in density between
saltwater and freshwater.
Maybe it came up from the sea.
That's not a mosasaur.
That's my mother-in-law!
Pudons!
Its belly looks swollen?
Oh gosh, it's gonna explode like the whales.
We should get out of here!
Ah!
Oh, we should get out of here, it does nothing.
Oh, sick!
Buddha!
Oh, no.
Oh, gross!
What the heck was that?
I once read about a whale carcass that washed the shore and
exploded.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Methane gas builds up from microbes in the stomach and
causes an explosion.
It doesn't have anything to do with the dinosaur itself, but
I knew exactly what kind of freaks they wrote Muna for.
I love her.
Oh, they knew.
Yeah, yeah.
They knew.
She is a bit of a freak.
I thought that's kind of dangerous though no like I think uh
I think you could get like seriously hurt from a whale
explosion like that oh no you worry me but I like your freak
seeing it in person is pretty horrifying my apologies may I
ask who you are sir I'm Panuta the village chief of
outsiders who have come to investigate the strange
occurrences in this village?
Yes, we experienced a similar phenomenon where we're from,
so we're looking for a connection.
Well, before it was the mermaid, so I wonder what's going on
here.
Until recently, we had frequent earthquakes.
They've less- wait, no, it wasn't the mermaids.
It was, uh, the mermaids were having the problem with the
earthquakes too.
It was, um, we had to go deep, deep, deep into the core.
There was something wrong with it.
Yeah.
You probably wouldn't be able to smell for a while.
No!
I gave myself COVID.
Yeah, the tree underwater.
Yeah, the divine tree got the mucus.
Yeah, it was sick.
It was sick.
This is my first exposure to this game.
You make it sound wild.
It's so funny because it's like...
Hi, I'm David.
the diver and I'm going swimming and I'm catching fish and
that it's like suddenly mermaids and dinosaurs but I mean at
the same time we it always kind of had the mystical aspect
of it because there were the earthquakes and the changing
biomes and well not changing biomes but the changing
underwater and things like that the lake has turned yellow
and polluted carcasses of creatures We've never seen before.
It keeps floating up.
Strange things continue to happen.
The villagers are still anxious.
That's exactly why we're here.
Don't worry.
The truth is, our village alone does not have the means to
handle this.
First, I have prepared houses for you all in the village.
So let us head there together.
Sounds like stardew.
Maybe?
Maybe.
I want to play some stardew.
It's been a long time.
for now one of you should remain here i'll see the others
housing arrangements boncho you look like you could use some
rest so why don't you take this one first i'm terribly sorry
chief do you happen to have anything to eat that's right
boncho must be starving since you threw up everything from
seeds like this play fields of mystery i've gotten good uh
i've heard good things about it yeah In the 70s in Florence,
Oregon, the local authorities tried to remove a beached
whale carcass with 450 kilograms of dynamite.
It didn't really work out the way they expected it to.
That sounds horrifying?
I can prepare something rather quickly.
Please wait a moment.
Thank you, I apologize for the trouble.
Cooking minigame?
Nope.
Wait, yes.
What do we have?
a fish the finest guys
I'm hungry I might go grab a snack oh he hates it oh they
did say the food here was really bad didn't they oh my god
it's that bad oh god this is like a Tomodachi life reaction
hope you have a sushi place near you.
Ah, white sushi.
This is really not good.
It's awful.
But Bancho, that's really rude.
He went out of his way to prepare this for us.
It was masked with a few spices, but the muddy taste has
completely gone away.
Hasn't completely gone away.
And if freshwater fish isn't cooked thoroughly, there's a
risk of parasites.
That's why you'll never catch me in a dang lake.
I'm not getting no brain-eating worm.
You'll never catch me in a lake.
The parasites.
How can you serve undercooked freshwater fish like this?
I appreciate the gesture, chief.
To speak ill of the cuisine of our people.
What a disrespectful young man.
Amoeba.
Oh, sure.
Whatever.
Whatever, nerd.
Poor Alan.
He's...
I don't know in there by choice kind of the taste of the
food has changed somewhat of late but that is due to the
lakes pollution I went out of my way to serve you and this
is how you respond I'm sure I'm so I'm sure I'm shall I'm
shall we shave Pertuna wait Pertuna
Bancho's a chef, so he's very particular about food.
A chef, you say.
I've heard cooks from the city rely heavily on artificial
seasonings.
You speak so because you do not understand the taste of
nature.
You go too far, chief.
Very well.
I shall prepare a dish using only ingredients from this
region.
I will inform you when I am ready, so please grant me some
time.
Do as you wish.
I'm showy.
I'm showy, Chaf.
They don't look so happy with us.
He's letting us stay here, and now you're making a scene.
I cannot accept that kind of cooking.
It's not good for the residents' health either.
I did think it tastes bad, too.
It's kind of refreshing to hear you say it.
Bancho, you're really something else.
Well, since it's come to this, let's focus on making
something good.
Good mindset.
First, we should consider what kind of fish can be found in
this area.
Tilapia!
Ooh, oh, this game's gonna make me hungry.
It's a fish that can produce a flavor most people enjoy.
I love tilapia.
Yummy, yummy.
Tilapia.
However, to eliminate the muddy taste, we'll need things
like fruits, herbs, and spices.
I'll look around and see if there's anything suitable
nearby.
we're foraging before you head into the lake i made some
tools while waiting for you all please come to my tent oh my
gosh munah we just met you today so forward don't read too
much about tilapia why never never mind don't tell me
maybe you've heard this lake has a freak a unique feature
the terrain shifts over time it's similar to the similar to
the phenomenon dr bacon was investigating at the blue hole.
Which is why I've been assigned to investigate you.
Recently earthquakes have become more frequent and the
water's gotten murky, making the fish quite sensitive.
As you saw, we've even found the remains of ancient
creatures.
Well, honestly, it's pretty great for my research.
No.
Anyway, if you go into the lake without proper gear right
now, you'll end up just saying.
Talapia stole my lunch money.
They've What a...
Tilapia all have a wasp inside them.
Just out...
Fig.
Fig, fig, fig, fig, fig.
I only brought a harpoon since I thought I'd just be
exploring the lake.
What should I do?
That's why I'm in a prepared this.
The jungle gun.
This gun can transform into four different forms.
Don't tell me your lab makes weapons too, Dr. Bichen.
And Muna just likes making weird stuff.
Archaeologists say Talapia had feathers.
Didn't we all?
I'll give you this jungle gun as a gift for helping with the
investigation.
This looks really useful.
Thanks, Muna!
Jungle gun.
The jungle can transform into different types of firearms.
Upgrade.
Huh.
I thought this would be easy, but guess not.
First I should get the tilapia boncho mention.
Let's go!
Oh, the village with bad food.
Chapter 1.
Oh, yes?
Greetings, outsider.
Yes, chief.
What is it?
I was so occupied discussing cooking earlier that I
neglected to mention.
Is this my?
Oh.
You may use this house as well.
Oh, great.
Thank you.
It is a bit old, but it should suffice for you to stay in
for a while.
Yeah, the map layout isn't flat today.
Arry, we're running around and stuff.
You are a diver, was it?
Yes, I'm a professional with quite a bit of experience.
I see.
If you wish to enter the lake, use the deck over there.
Whoa.
The lake is not in great condition at the moment, Go too
deep.
Okay.
That won't stop me.
Let's go find some dinosaurs.
Run to the dinosaurs.
Whoa!
Quick change.
Here we go.
Gimme in the water, baby.
Was the original not 3D?
It wasn't.
Oh wait, no, there were some parts that were 3D.
Because you could plant, I remember.
The jungle can switch between forms for different
situations.
use scroll.
Oh, what was this?
Oh, okay, there we go.
What are you?
That's not a tilapia.
You are!
Oh.
Oops.
Wait, we need the gun, right?
Oh, these are just... I think we can get away with this,
right?
It's a fish.
A red discus.
It is pretty, right?
Too
much ammo.
What does a tilapia look like?
Not this guy, surely.
You, you, you.
A green discus.
Wait, let's...
No, a blue discus?
Do my eyes deceive me?
Ah!
Wait, I was actually right.
Tilapia have a mohawks.
Wait, what is that?
What are you guys?
Don't leave me.
Don't leave me!
A brown discus.
Too many discuses.
Three out of ten.
Down there, it looks really murky.
Tilapia usually stay near the surface, so I don't need to go
too deep.
Oh!
Guys, I think we found our fish.
Wait, what is it?
Oh, the smell's too strong.
What do you mean the smell?
Imagine the Smell.
Nice.
Mud smell.
Imagine the smell of the fish.
We'll get multiple tilapias.
I want to just explore a little bit more.
I guess we can't go down too far though, right?
He says it's too smelly.
Smell?
The smell.
But the smell...
What does it smell like?
Stinky, stinky.
Is this a yellow...
Wait, did we get a yellow discus before?
Oh, it's a green discus.
Am I crazy?
That's yellow, no.
Dang, are we...
Oh my gosh, it's like we just beat the game.
Shouldn't wander too far right now.
Better stay near the village.
Okay.
Looks yellow to me.
It's pink!
No.
This is definitely the green one though.
Oops, not you.
A heckle discus!
Now they're just making up colors.
We have so much weight.
Awesome.
Ah!
Oh, I'm poisoned.
No, come back!
I want to eat you!
Oh, they hide in there.
Little bitch.
Oh, I missed.
No!
A walking catfish.
What?
But it swims.
That's so weird.
Yeah, they are tanky.
But we're strong.
I guess I could have used my gun.
That would have been the perfect opportunity to use a gun.
But you know.
We tank it.
We're that good.
What's that?
I hardly even know, or...
Stinky, stinky!
Oh, I feel so good to play this again.
Yeah, we're just that good, we're just that good.
I guess I could kill the other one.
I'll kill your brother.
Or your wife.
Whichever one that was.
I'll kill your whole family.
What's that?
This area is blocked off with steaks, I wonder why.
Mmm, steak.
Why does it think I'm hungry?
Not for vampires.
Walking catfish, my biggest fish, baby.
Yep.
Wait, what does this do?
Oh, my gear.
Okay.
Gotta get back into the game, baby.
Ooh.
chickens chickens not the best game to play while hungry
that's okay I'll go grab a snack oh no more lizards please
huge boulder is blocking path lizard lizard oh no they have
bamboo it's so over for them it's so over for them it's
gonna destroy the entire village it's gonna take over
everywhere is there actually any way to get rid of bamboo
like once it starts the door is closed wait her more lizards
fire that seems a little bit overkill maybe wow it's so
beautiful okay i'm gonna leave you this while i go get a
snack i'm so sorry concrete no not even concrete it
literally it literally goes through concrete and stuff too
you can dig it out i guess maybe right
i'm gonna get a snack beep beep beep beep i'll be right back
oh it's stretchy
okay all right i've got my snack now We're right back.
Wait a second.
I just brought the whole thing.
It is peanut butter princess.
The bestest ever.
Good snack.
I don't want to ruin my appetite for a dinner.
This pizza burger eats peanut butter.
Did you bring it up for all the Iboos?
It's a huge container.
Costco.
All right, Banjo, do your thing, do your thing.
This lake is huge.
Yeah, did you see the guy that washed up the shore?
I was just thinking Costco.
Yeah.
I got the tilapia you mentioned.
Thank you, I looked around the area a bit.
Fortunately, there was a calamansi tree nearby, so I picked
some fruit.
The scent of calamansi helps neutralize the muddiness,
making it ideal for freshwater fish dishes.
What's a calamansi?
It would be perfect if we had some herbs and spices to
advance the flavor.
Tiny citrus.
The smell.
You must be the outsiders who came to investigate the
village.
My eyesight isn't very good.
So I rely on scent instead.
What do we smell like?
Famous fruit in Filipino cuisine.
Maybe I have had it before, though, and I just didn't know.
Hmm.
We smell like gargantuan.
We smell like a baca.
A veneager.
We were told some strange things have been happening
recently.
We came to investigate the lake here.
Thank you.
I can tell from your voice that you are a kind person.
A while ago, there were frequent earthquakes.
Now ancient creatures are washing ashore.
So many troubling things have been happening recently.
Or lately.
I'm just an old woman who gathers and sells herbs.
Oh my god!
Herb seller.
Sniff sniff man flesh.
What is that?
You!
But if there's anything I can do...
help please let me know oh we forgive my asking so abruptly
but do you happen to have any herbs suitable for cooking oh
so you're a cook I could smell the ingredients on you I have
some lemongrass what do you think lemon with a lemon with
lemon grass tastes like a lemon because that's perfect for a
fish perfect may I purchase some from you you come all this
way so consider it a gift this time.
With this I can make something delicious.
I hope it helps you make something delicious.
I'm Lathi.
I live in the house on the right side of the village.
If you ever need spices, stop by anytime.
Nice.
Nathi.
All right.
buys and sells various spices coconut milk wait this is so
this all sounds so good this should suffice have the village
chief come here around dinner time it has been some time
since I last worked with these ingredients so I shall
prepare them in advance friend unlocked friend added to my
notebook
the chief should be here soon
make an old man with bad legs like me come and go just go
like this i expected to be worth the trouble i can't wait to
have him to have his uh what was that anime where everybody
would lose their clothes after eating food uh kitchen
nightmares yeah food wars yeah yeah yeah
must eat and wait a moment.
I shall have the meal ready shortly.
He's gonna have his food wars moment.
I am the server.
I am serving.
I'm serving.
Would you like some water?
For you?
Oh, your mouth open.
Oh my god.
The flavor slapped him in the face.
Are these truly the same ingredients?
The flavor is completely different.
Kitchen Nightmare is with Gordon Ramsay, but every time he
starts screaming, his clothes explode off his body.
I'd pay to see it.
The texture is similar, but the aroma, what an incredible
aroma.
That's how you know it's good.
He still has his clothes on, though, I would say we actually
failed.
Freshwater fish tend to have a strong muddy flavor, so they
must be thoroughly soaked in calamansi juice to remove it,
especially with the pungent smell from this lake.
Lemongrass must be used to properly mask it.
I shall admit it.
You seem to know a thing or two about cooking fish.
Lutara Lake is known for its diverse fish population, since
you will be staying here for a while.
How would you feel about preparing meals for our residents?
That is a big ass.
I would like to repay your kindness for allowing us to stay
in the village.
But we are staying in the village because they need help.
So they're getting help and then also...
Then also making us pay for everything?
Or feed everybody?
That meal really slaps.
But...
What was I going to say?
The one thing I remember from Food Wars that I always...
wanted to try was some like sort of bacon wrapped meat and
the way they animated it my mouth is literally watering it
was so it was it looked so good oh my god the fake pork yeah
it was it was episode 1 wasn't it it was it was yeah it was
the mashed potatoes that's right oh it sounded so good like
it stuck with me I think I only watched season one of Food
Wars, so that of everything in that season, that is the
thing that stuck with me the most.
Oh, so good.
It was so good.
Did you ever try to make it?
I shouldn't be in the kitchen.
If I must gather all the ingredients myself, it may be prove
difficult to serve everybody properly.
That is understandable.
One of people in the northern part of the village grows
papayas and coconuts i shall grant you free access to those
ingredients oh and the fish in the lake have been quite
aggressive lately yeah the catfish literally bit my butt if
you're in danger cut open a coconut in the water and i'll
send down a rescue pod that's good to know i've heard the
fish have become incredibly aggressive though there were
some rather beautiful ones too with all these strange
occurrences the residents may be a bit on edge I hope you
understand aren't made supposed to know how to cook please
don't don't please understand I I am a maid cafe maid I
bring my magic and I and blessings to your food I do not
prepare anything I am not a maid that you believe that I am
damn
it Gem she's a maid not a cook
You put together stuffed peppers once?
No, I bought stuffed peppers.
I purchased.
They were already stuffed.
I just threw them in the oven.
Snake taught me anything's edible.
That's so true.
You aren't responsible for the spelling mistakes on my
omelette rice?
Oh, well, I mean, I do that at your table, right?
Can you moi moi kune your own food or that, NG?
It's typically, like, kind of cringe.
Not gonna lie.
The omu rice was a lie.
No!
Oh, that's the ketchup.
I shall be counting on you.
If you require anything, come visit the house in the north
of the village.
Oh, my gosh.
He loves me.
Whoa, level up.
Relationship.
Option two, get in the wet rose dress.
dress all cook.
I had a dream last night that they messaged me.
This is a dream.
I had a dream that they messaged me on Twitter and were just
like, we did not give you approval for our dress to be in
the music video.
What was that about?
And it was a dream.
Just to make, just so everybody understands that Wet Rose
cosplay did not actually message me, but they messaged me in
my dream.
They were We did not give you permission.
You must re-edit, burn on with you completely naked.
To be fair.
They did not do that for real.
But yeah.
Option two, get in the white rose dress.
I'll cook.
Putting minto checki on food is moi moi boo.
Yeah.
I want to tell you how much I loved your minty cheese.
Karaoke.
I was great.
like a big dummy the whole time thank you thank you thanks
for liking it sorry every time i click out of the game it
stops the music but i have to do that sometimes or read some
of your messages i'm unsure how many residents will come but
i need to cook anyway if you come across any good
ingredients bring them to me got it oh no now we're gonna be
serving people no i'm supposed to be fixing this village we
need to cook there What a long day.
Came all this way and met so many new people.
Looks like there's still a lot to do, but I'll just do what
I can while I'm here.
Should get a good night's sleep.
Yes.
Bed looks stiff.
It's hay.
But the village chief went out of his way to set this up for
me.
A stiff bed is not bad.
Crack your back or something.
She's serving people.
It's paper.
I'm so tired.
I'll probably fall asleep right away anyway.
That's been me, like, every night.
That's been me, every night.
As soon as I...
Man, I'm just like...
Hey, on.
Good morning, Mito.
It gets a bit chilly at night.
It feels like there's a draft.
I guess I can't complain.
I did take this place on short notice.
Do we get to upgrade our shack?
no oh goodness gracious is she smelly oh no that's her
shadow Dave oh good burning GMD good morning Dave what's up
Muna you're headed down to the lake rye could I ask you with
some to help with some research I'd be happy if I help if I
can smells like rotten eggs and stings I don't think I can
go very deep.
That's due to hydrogen sulfide.
It's a gas produced by decaying organic matter.
It's that bad in there!
Should we be eating these fish?
Toxic substance.
It tends to accumulate where fresh water meets salt water
due to differences in density.
This lake probably had some to begin with.
But I suspect the concentration increased significantly
because massive creatures like dinosaurs died and piled up
in a short period.
H2S will kill.
I see.
Then this research might be difficult after all.
What are you talking about?
Do you think Muna, the dark angel of this lab, would ask for
something without a plan?
Muna is our Chunibyo e-kitten.
Use this.
Watch this.
It's a purification filter.
With this, some of the hydrogen sulfide should be filled.
filtered out.
I made it in a hurry, so you won't be able to go too deep.
But I'll keep researching and see if I can improve it.
The Dark Angel.
Looks like it'll help quite a lot with exploring the lake.
So what can I help you with?
No.
I'm looking for some local folklore.
Scientific analysis is important, but studying old legends
can help us understand why these things are happening here.
I read through some writings from the village chief, and it
seems like the ancient Sunang people ventured deep into the
lake.
In other words, they knew how to get past the hydrogen
sulfide.
But isn't it worse because dinosaurs are dying, right?
Casually experimenting with Dave's life.
Right?
There must be traces of that at the bottom of the lake.
If you find any sculptures at the bottom of the lake, could
you bring them to me?
Got it.
Okay.
We got our purification filter.
Nice.
to dive deep into the hydrogen sulfide filled lake a
purification filter is essential okay
and the jungle time flows in real time during the day that
dive in the lake or gather resources to prepare for the
restaurant at night okay jungle live wait we can upgrade our
stuff though no
Oh, I need...
What are those?
Shells?
Well, never mind.
See ya.
Retrieve the ancient statue.
Wait, who's this kid?
Oh, he's playing with a coconut?
First of all.
Hey, uh, I'm Dave.
Just staying in this village for a bit.
So you're with that glasses girl who came here recently.
I'm Eka.
Mr. Do you have any games on your phone?
Yeah, a few?
Can I try one?
No way, he said the thing.
He said the thing.
I'll give it back soon.
Thanks.
He's actually playing it.
I died.
What did you play?
Evil Factory?
Nope, that looked boring.
I played bouncy Dumbo.
It's super fun.
Let me play again.
next time evil factory is fun though guess kids these days
have different what do we have wait what's on our phone oh i
remember leah's run evil factory crush the kraken's
conspiracy i remember this one too i think i remember how to
play it it's cow clicker wait what's no the bouncy one can't
be give him cow clicker Oh god!
Oh my
gosh.
Hi!
Wait, I'm doing it wrong?
Oh, I'm doing it wrong?
Yeah!
Wait, I'm pressing it though.
Oh, that's interesting.
Fu?
That's an interesting place to Fuwa Fuwa.
Hi!
Wait, why is it?
Oh, ah!
There!
Oh, you do both at the same time!
Hi!
Oh!
Yeah!
Blu-blu-blu-blu-blu!
They had the spirit.
They had a good spirit.
What's evil factory though?
It says a game demo.
Intruder.
Okay, I don't know what to do, but...
Wait, she's so cute?
Kraken soldiers up ahead!
Only three?
It's way easier than I thought.
Don't underestimate them.
Kraken weapons are tough.
Yeah, if they can use it.
Hope you remember how to use your weapon.
This is not the tutorial.
Intruder!
Kill him!
No, I...
Oh.
What's Control do?
Oops.
Why am I looking up?
Nice!
Control!
That guy's just on fire.
Oh, that's it.
I'm out.
He's totally dead.
Oh, time warp.
That's what I was doing.
Was that you at the last show you went to?
That's me at every show I go to.
That's it, Leo.
You may be a jerk, but you've got skills.
I'm sure they heard that explosion, so stay sharp.
Good.
I won't need to look for them.
Right.
Once you defeat the enemy, you can move to the next floor.
Go to the elevator, shown by the arrow.
I think I'm good, though.
Wait, why is there a timer?
Oh, this elevator.
I think I'm good, though.
Can I leave?
Can I leave the game?
I'm ready to fish again.
I'm ready to fish.
Whoa.
Can you get me on here?
Ah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah.
Stop!
Why did she say that?
Okay.
Let's go.
Can't be playing games on my phone all day, you guys.
We gotta go deeper into the water.
I was pressing escape, it wouldn't let me know.
Black piranha.
Wait, is that him?
He's gonna get my butt.
What are you?
Oh, oh, this is tilapia.
Suddenly they're everywhere.
Okay, sure.
Suddenly we have tilapia by the dozens.
Tilapia's stonks are through the roof.
We'll get more so that we can...
Oops.
Yeah, we gotta feed the restaurant, baby.
Wait, are those tiny fish?
Wait, those are tiny fish, aren't they?
What are you, tiny, tiny fish?
What the heck are you, tiniest fish?
You're the tiniest fish I've ever seen.
What are you, tiny fish?
A chocolate gorami!
I've always wanted one!
I don't know.
I've never heard of him before.
Come on, oh no, you're getting in my way!
Oh, Bluegill, that guy's new, no?
Oh, they're so small.
They're actually the tiniest fish.
Chocolate gorami.
Where's he going?
in my tummy.
Oh wait, this is a thing.
Maracas.
Wait, actually.
Oh.
So small, they only need one popcorn.
It's actually fine with the purification filter.
Better explore before it runs out.
Oh, okay.
What is this?
Oh, bone fragment.
Ingredient.
Okay.
Fish sauce.
What's this?
Lakevine.
Used for crafting furniture?
Wait, we will actually be decorating!
What are you?
Brown discuss.
Moss ball.
It actually was a moss ball!
I was just making that up.
Fish sauce, yeah.
This whole game.
is yum what are you wait that's a tilapia no tilapia on the
menu boys
okay so that oh
the hydrogen sulfide is too dense down here i better not go
any deeper come to think of it muna said she can modify
okay wait oh shoot ah no no come back come back come get me
oh No, no, please.
Oh, my God.
I keep missing.
Oh, no!
Uh-oh.
Wait, I'm dead.
I'm dying.
I'm dead.
I'm messed up, guys.
We gotta go back.
Sambal sauce.
That sounds amazing.
With garlic and...
No!
You guys are stinky!
You stupid!
The catfish are so annoying!
Alright, alright.
We gotta go find the statue though.
Wait, can I talk to her about it?
Can I be like, your thing sucks and I need an upgrade stat?
Help me.
Talk.
Looking at teeth and fins?
I'm sure it's bastiosaurus.
But it's way too small.
Maybe you could be a baby.
The Bastillosaurus.
Technically it's not a dinosaur.
More like an ancient whale.
But let's just call it that for convenience.
That's kind of what I do too though.
Where it's like...
I just say dinosaur to incorporate all prehistoric things.
It's blasphemous, I know.
But still...
Its size does seem a bit small.
Not our dino.
It's old, instantly dinosaur, right?
Just like grandpa.
Hope that helped.
Alright, we'll have to talk to her later.
Wait, can I fix anything here?
I forgot I can dash.
With that little charm.
Woolly mammoth must be a dino.
Actually.
Wait, I'm going to lock up my pretzels so I don't
accidentally knock them off.
Make a mess.
Alright, so we're going off to find a statue of some kind.
A boob array.
Wait, did I lose?
I lost my Maracas.
That sucks.
Pretzels.
Ketzels?
Pretzels?
One of the same.
All right, now we're in the bad zone.
We got cilantro!
Do you have the gene?
Do you have the bad cilantro gene?
Oh my god, the piranha...
Oh my god.
That's a red-bellied piranha!
They're ruthless!
My sister has it.
I do not...
I hate cilantro.
Freaking love cilantro.
For you.
Ow, daiku!
Different kind of ferocity from sea creatures.
I better be careful.
I'm scared.
I was scared.
A large fan.
Generates a current when attacking.
Okay, interesting.
The stone with the coconut must be an escape.
tool the chief mentioned I'll have to use him when getting
out of the water okay but where are the piranhas I'm so
scared wait what's under here wait oh can I use wait can I
use that anywhere no oh
I have no fish bait oh wait that's guy wait is he the bad
guy he's red-eyed but he's not red-bellied oh my god oh my
going holy cow he's chomping away at me no no don't you
leave get back here i don't want you calling your friends
over he actually just he just left completely okay bozo wait
no he's gonna to get that.
Oh my god.
Die already!
There we go.
We got a black piranha tooth.
Wait, what's this up here?
Oh my gosh, it's a statue!
We were done!
The statue we needed.
Let's head back.
Not quite.
Hold on.
I have much more to get, probably.
I just gotta watch out for more piranhas.
Oh gosh, they were scary.
You taste the blood in the water.
Too scary.
Oh, are those le- oh, lemongrass.
I thought it was leeks.
I want to keep exploring.
I guess we can't go too far down anymore.
Oh.
Oh shoot, uh-oh, uh-oh, okay.
Escape pod!
Woof, that was close.
Fleet, I guess they have those because of the O2 meter being
able to run out.
That's pretty nice.
My depth 38 meters.
Nice.
It was not good quality, but that's okay.
Can we serve people now?
now.
Saved by the bell.
Is this that kid?
Wait, what's this?
A branch!
Okay.
Maybe I should take a break.
I'm gonna keep going.
Breaks are for suckers.
Is that a beetle?
Can I grab... No!
I wanted to grab them.
I feel like I'm an animal crossing all of a sudden.
I'm picking up sticks and stuff.
Very cool to have.
I heard you can't eat freshwater fish raw.
Unfortunately, that's true.
The taste isn't great.
And more importantly, they can carry parasites.
The parasites.
It's a shame I won't be able to have your sushi for a while,
Bancho.
It is what it is.
I'll make the best dishes I can with what I have.
Bancho out of his element.
Tom Nook needs his sticks.
I gotta sell them for pennies.
Is this the sculpture you mentioned?
It's pretty damaged.
The sculpture is an ancient diver?
Looking at this, I think I'm starting to understand.
Using equipment like this and doing this?
I'll look into it further.
We got cash!
Let's go.
Looking at the writings the village chief had.
The ancient Sunang people placed stone tablets deep in the
lake to pray for safety.
There might be clues on those stone tablets.
Money, money, baby.
Could you...
There should be around three of them.
photos for me.
I didn't see any when I went earlier.
Could they be deeper down?
I don't think the current purification filter can handle
that.
You're right.
To upgrade the purification filter we'll need to study the
contaminants a bit more.
I'm analyzing the dinosaur carcass that drifted to the
village.
But I need more data.
Contaminated bone... Isn't that what I've been bringing,
though?
Contaminated bone fragments.
Okay.
Sorry.
I kind of like skipped through the stuff there a little bit.
Well, how many do I need?
No.
Full...
Wait, I can't.
Oh, it costs money.
She's charging me an arm and a leg for her own research.
Are we for real right now?
No.
Okay.
Hope that helped.
It didn't.
Let's go help with Prab!
She's a girly in debt.
You're so right.
it we'll get we should get the money here though no like
working right chapter two jungle live gotta pay off the
crypto seems you're ready to open most impressive where did
we get the light from oh chief thanks to you we've got
everything sorted out quickly we're planning to start
serving food to the villagers today oh well they did have a
car never mind we've stocked up on ingredients as well i've
informed the villagers that you will be opening a restaurant
but i am unsure how many will come places yeah but just
whatever anywhere don't worry about the light if you leave a
badge of recognition here the villagers may trust you a bit
more mouse deer what is that it's so cute the villagers
minke cheese my minke cheese coin that i can Huge, huge,
huge!
Thank you.
Let's hope the villagers feel more at ease now.
How do I raise a badge's rating?
I shall tell you a few conditions.
Fulfill them and I will grant you a new badge.
All right.
Oh, he didn't tell us.
I'll tell you.
Leaves.
Minty mouse.
No.
Minty cheese.
Wait.
Yes, minty cheese.
Your shop will Run your shop well to earn higher grade
badges Oh, okay Here we go Add to the menu
Mmm, let's see what we got The chocolate gourami Ouch Wait,
we have so much tilapia Wait, I can How do I enhance it?
What do I need to enhance it?
Okay, we're enhancing
Yippee Yay!
Alright!
Oh gosh, I cannot remember how to do this.
Wait, okay, we can add it to the menu.
Let's just do that, right?
I think that's fine, just doing it like this.
We'll do the discuses.
Wait, uh, manage.
Auto supply, I guess?
Yeah, I think that's what you do.
Auto supply.
And maybe a chocolate gourami.
Squack!
I know the animations in this game are so funny.
Okay.
Now we should be good.
I have nothing to research, so that's fine.
Let's open it up, baby!
Discuses is a grill master parrot, the newest chef on Mother
Bay.
Yes, I'm hungry after that workout.
Yes, of course.
One of those.
Yes.
There you go.
So good.
I moved.
Mona's here.
Oh, you.
Wait, how do I get that?
Coconut.
Do I get that for you?
Oh.
Oh, dang!
I did it.
First try.
Let's go.
It's a drink, yeah.
She's getting hungry.
Yes, yes, yes.
Oh.
They both want something.
All right.
First you.
Yes.
Tastes great.
I know.
Feels like I'm going to collapse.
You're fine.
You're fine, you're fine, you're fine, you're fine.
Chill, chill, chill.
Oh, this guy's still hungry.
You want seconds?
She's so hungry.
Moon is so dramatic.
I know, right?
This is taking a while.
You just put in the order.
I don't want to hear it.
The aroma is quite nice.
Oh, we're out of some stuff now already.
Starving to death here.
What did we run out of?
What was that one?
Oh, he's still hungry?
Come on, Bancho!
I'm running, I'm running!
A bit late.
Puts in the order immediately.
Hang on, hang on, hang, hang, hang on.
That was a tough night, guys.
Oh, yeah!
We earned Artisan's Flame.
I'm rich, rich, yeah.
everybody loved it no haters here just as i thought not many
villagers coming by me sweating panting dripping sweat
literally down my shirt down my pants and my underwear down
my legs to my toes it's so i've been busting my butt running
everywhere at boncho you say that but as soon as they put in
an order they are ready to they are they are they're they're
ravenous estate how many villagers are coming by I think
they're a bit wary of us are you gonna give us a glowing
review and tell everybody why is Rena from Higurashi why is
her little sickle thing over here you must be the outsiders
who are you I thought yo you were the one who brought us
food I was gonna say she was the one that brought us the
nasty fish I'm Usmi the village chief's daughter Thank you
for the food yesterday.
The face was really quite terrible.
Bancho!
It's okay.
I tried a proper chef's cooking at the restaurant earlier,
and it was on a whole different level.
What do you think of the new Higurashi project announced?
Yeah, they're like redoing the first anime.
I don't know how to feel.
But also, I'm all for more Higurashi music.
If we can get like a more...
It's a new story?
Oh, wait, is it?
I won't get baited by Ryukishi again.
Wait, I thought it was a remake of the first.
Unless?
We'll see.
Anyway.
Call me Banjo.
Nice to meet you, Banjo.
I was about to say, I think she likes him.
Or rather, when she was like, nice to meet you.
I thought...
Wait, she...
And who's this with you?
I'm Dave, a professional...
professional diver.
Cheers, Anna, Kanye.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Nice to meet you, Dave.
If you don't mind.
How about I show you around the village?
That sounds great.
I've been curious about a lot of things while exploring.
He'll be staying here for a while.
I thought it'd be nice if you got to know the village a bit
better.
I have some cleaning up to do.
Thanks for the offer, but you two go ahead.
Oh no!
Boncho!
Boncho, she's into you!
Dang.
The fumble.
Come on.
Have you heard about the recent earthquakes?
No.
I heard the fish have become more sensitive because of it.
That's right.
Recently there was a major earthquake.
Oh, sorry.
A rock spell.
The path to Setah Forest has been blocked.
It's good that wild animals can't get in, but I'm worried
things have never used to happen are happening lately.
Anime in Toho 6 remake, 2026 is 2002.
So true.
It's awesome.
Oh, at night.
Crocodiles come to the lake to rest at night.
They won't attack without warning, but it's best not to go
into the lake at night.
Wait.
When I was young, my father was injured by a crocodile.
While trying to save me.
That's why he has trouble with his legs.
That is why he has trouble with his legs.
This is the sandy beach.
Where villagers gather by bonfire or enjoy the night air.
Or I guess there's no night air to be...
We're not going to address the elephant in the room.
We're going to enjoy the air by this...
Ah, yes, the fresh air of the beach and the pungent scent of
rotting corpse.
Ah, yes.
Ah, ah, yes.
Oh, it's a beautiful place, but that dinosaur carcass does
smell a bit.
I heard it suddenly floated in at night and startled the
residents.
I can imagine how shocking that must have been.
Ah, the stench.
Just like how they got used to the nasty food, I'm sure
they'll get used to this stench.
as well address me what
are they doing telling ghost stories there's some men
sitting by the bonfire today I wonder if they're gossiping
about their wives hey did you see the new Madoka movie
trailer I did see that there was one but I'm so behind on
Madoka I'm quite behind I can't I it's one of those series
that like I couldn't keep up because They would take a
million year gaps in between and then there was like the
mobile game and all this stuff I don't know, maybe I'll
rewatch it someday.
I did like it a lot.
So Just watch rebellion.
Oh, yeah.
Is that like a recap movie kind of?
Why is the music so country?
I come to look at the lake when I have a lot on my mind.
Dave, do you have any worries?
Oh, I'm a bit worried that the villagers aren't really
coming to our restaurant even though we worked hard
preparing the ingredients.
It goes Anime Rebellion New Movie.
No way, really?
That's it?
Oh, I'm just making it more tough than it is.
The villagers probably won't be quick to try an outsider's
cooking.
Try talking with them or how about giving them gifts?
Oh, my gosh.
This is becoming Stardew Valley for real.
It's a tradition in our village to give and receive gifts.
That sounds like a good idea.
Everyone has different tastes, so it would be good to learn
their preferences.
What the heck?
You can now give gifts to villagers.
If they like your gift, you'll gain a lot of affinity.
Now that I think about it, have you had any trouble getting
around the village?
Actually, the houses all look pretty similar.
The bribery!
I'm not used to it yet, so it's a bit confusing.
That happens when you're new somewhere.
Oh, thank goodness.
You'll be able to find people in places much more easily.
This will really help.
Thank you.
Same goes for Banjo.
I'm happy when everyone feels comfortable here.
Wishy-blowsy.
Oh, okay.
Interesting.
You can still do activities after business hours, but if you
stay up too late, it'll affect your performance the next
day.
Okay.
Cool.
I've been wondering what this is this entire time.
A dark brown river snail shell.
Can I do anything with this guy?
What's this do?
Maybe I should join by the bonfire.
Join?
Oh, well get the affinity up!
That's what it seems like.
Star Diver Valley.
I just...
Come on, hurry up!
and carving don't rush me i might oh sorry i'm i'm going i'm
pushing faster than what i'm reading say where are you from
do you have things like animal block stacking challenges
what's that city folks really are no fun you stack animal
blocks and whoever knocks them over loses a few of my a few
mine broke so i got gassang here making me some new ones
Figured he could make a little side cash while he's at it.
Behind his scary wife's back.
Says Jenga, baby.
Reverse Jenga.
No, they don't say things like that in front of outsiders.
But it's true, isn't it?
You can't even buy a few coconut drinks with that tiny
allowance.
If Ward gets out about this, I might not get any allowance
at all.
Guess it's the same everywhere.
Outsider, if you're interested in the animal block stacking
challenge, the afternoon.
I tend to sleep in a bit.
I'll be by the blocked boulder.
Okay, I know where that is.
Harta is his name.
Kasang and Harta.
What is this?
This is Animal Crossing.
Starfruit!
Oh, I love starfruit!
Yummy!
Yummy, yummy, yummy starfruit.
What's over here?
Nothing.
Who are you?
Hello, I'm Dave.
I came to this village for research.
Oh, you're reading.
Sorry to interrupt.
Oh, it's fine.
I'm Kina.
It means peace of mind.
Do you enjoy reading, Dave?
She's so cute.
Of course, reading a book with a cocktail on the beach is
absolute heaven.
Haha, we're on the same page.
What have you been reading lately?
That's about a guy preparing for an exam to join the
anti-monster defense force, but he suddenly turns into a
monster himself.
But he gains incredible physical abilities, so he passes the
exam anyway while struggling with being a monster at the
same time.
That's a comic book, isn't it?
He's reading Kaiju Number A.
Is that what it really is?
Oh, that's so funny.
It's really fun, I swear!
You should check it out!
I'll see.
I'll think about it.
Well then, back to my poetry.
Oh, she's too cultured for us.
She reads poetry.
I read manga.
She's cheered captain and I read manga.
What's that?
Well, these are the guys that I already know.
Get me out of here.
There's so many crocodiles.
No, please, please, please.
Hang in.
These guys are glowing.
These flowers here?
Are they special?
Pink evening primrose.
Ooh, and yellow version.
Cool.
So there's like nighttime stuff.
Can't you see?
Hey, you ought to read manga.
I'm on the bleachers reading Inuyasha.
That was a lizard.
I'm going to catch him one day.
I'm going to catch you.
I'm going to catch you one day.
Speaking of reading, there's something that...
There's a bit of a project that I want to put out sometime
soon-ish.
Wait, I'm going to get this guy.
Ow!
somewhat soon-ish which is I want them because I like to
listen to these Kibawa how was the game how was the game
hello oh go to bed um oh yeah Kimawa Hello Wait, did Kimawa
just read?
Oh, hello.
Not good, apparently.
Oh, no.
Which one I should ask?
Oh.
Football?
Oh, did she not read?
That's okay.
But yeah, there's a bit of a project that I kind of want to
do because I like to listen to audiobooks while going to
sleep.
So I want to record some audiobooks.
Oh, there were multiple games today.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Brazil versus Japan and Paraguay versus Germany.
Oh, I watched like three games a day.
Oh, this shows how much I'm paying attention to soccer.
What I think I'll do first is I will do...
I have a couple of the Metal Gear books.
So if you're interested in those, I probably will do like a
couple...
And they'll be long.
So it will be like one really long video that you can fall
asleep to.
So I just have to record them when I have time.
So probably like several hours worth of reading.
in the background and fall asleep too um so yeah yeah yeah
and then it could be something that you um if you're
interested in the book it's like an audiobook and if you
want to fall asleep to it then you can fall asleep to it um
so i'll probably start with i have a metal gear one two and
four that are translated so probably start with those and
then maybe do some other light novels or something in the
future so yeah some some some audio minto audio books
minto audio books that i've been wanting to do i would buy a
mint audio book well honestly i mean i can't sell them
because i i'm not you know would it be on the channel it
would be on the channel yeah yeah so you don't have three.
I don't think they made a three.
I want to look it up.
Metal Gear Solid, like, at least in English.
Let's see.
Metal Gear Solid 3 book.
Members only?
No, no.
That'll be for everybody.
Yeah, yeah.
No, it wouldn't be in parts.
It would all be at once.
But that's what will take me the longest part is because i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to record it in parts but
um a really good book i've heard called something like dirty
filthy nasty that has the best audio book narration i cannot
beat it i can't beat it filthy nasty boss i can't beat that
one starring enzo manchini Well, we get some nice page
turning sounds.
Probably because, uh...
But I have to flip the books or flip the pages, no.
But yeah, it's kind of, it's for, it's for, you know,
everybody to listen to.
And also, it's also for myself so that I can finally read
the novelizations of Metal Gear.
So yeah.
Yeah, that's something that I've been working on.
Yeah.
I'd like to get them out by the end of the year, which is
quite a long time from now.
But like I said, I have to read the whole book and record it
and get it all out in one part.
So maybe I could get the first part out done in like
October, November, December.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
It is quite a bit of reading.
Yeah, so I have to be not as busy.
Not as busy.
I don't want to release them chapter by chapter though.
I probably will have it separated by chapters in the video
itself so that you can know where you stop if you so
inclined.
You know, if you wish that.
But, but, uh, yeah.
Yeah, I'd like it to be one full video just so that like it
all plays at once whenever you want to listen to it.
And then, and then, of course, no, I mean, I wouldn't, I
usually don't put ads on my stuff anyway, but there would be
no ads on it anyway.
So, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, so metal
gear, audio book.
Also, I don't, I mean, like, also, I was thinking, because,
like, I don't think there is an audio book of it all,
probably, most likely, no?
So, I was like, it'd be kind of fun to have something, even
if it's my own, if it's unofficial, right?
So, hmm.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's what I've been really wanting to work on it.
Okay.
The roof's leaking.
No!
So much for a good night's sleep.
sleep.
Aw, man.
Aw, he just rolls over and takes it.
Chairs die, isn't it?
How long would the video be?
I mean, I don't...
Oh, also, I was gifted.
I was gifted the Bioshock novel as well.
Thank you, I was gifted the Bioshock novel too, so I could
probably do that one in the future as well.
Hold on, I'm looking at my bookshelf.
Wait, let me grab one.
Let me see how long they are.
Middle year solid.
It is.
Let's see.
It has an epilogue.
Revolver Ocelot listened to the other man on the line, then
spoke.
Yes.
Metal Gear Solid is only 319 pages.
Metal Gear Solid 2 is...
308 pages.
And then Metal Gear Solid 4 is much bigger.
360 pages.
This one, though, I think is the one that kind of, like,
adds the most, because it's, like, from Otakon.
Otakon.
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry.
I was thinking of the convention Otakon's perspective.
So, yeah.
So, yeah, there would be a couple hours.
Good enough to get a good night's sleep, probably.
So, uh-huh.
Let me put these back on my shelf.
I do also, I do also have the Metal Gear Peace Wall.
in book form but it's Japanese only.
That's achievable compared to lots of novels, right?
I feel like it too.
And then I asked, what's wrong with E?
It is good speaking and pronunciation practice maybe for me.
Annunciation practice.
Are the books the same at the game?
At least the one and two are, but four is a little...
I mean, it's a different perspective for four, so yeah.
Anyway.
I barely slept because of the rain, and now who could that
be?
Someone knocking?
I should check it out.
The old house.
Hello?
Morning.
Did you sleep well?
No, the roof was leaking all night, so I couldn't sleep
well.
My clothes are all damp, too.
yeah that happens when a place is left unattended for too
long gets tired of translate he would kill me he would
actually actually but i want to kill him so he would kill me
but he can't kill me i'm already dead
i can't even imagine how i mean he did just translate the
new steinsgate that's basically a novel it is a novel so
it's not that he's He couldn't.
But at the same time, I don't want his translation.
A visual novel even!
Exactly!
It is a novel, a name!
Just do it again and for free!
It's not for free, I pay that guy!
Hey there, buddy!
You're ready for something that's a little out of the scope
of your contract?
Yeah, maybe like Higurashi or Umineko.
Those would be really long though.
Those would be super long to narrate.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I'm new here.
How are you able to play the DLC if it needs you to finish
the base game?
Oh, um, actually, it says that, and I have finished the game
before.
I don't think it picked up on it, though.
But I have finished it.
It just let me play it.
It just said, like, hey, if you haven't finished the main
game, we recommend you do so.
So don't let that scare you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Let me help you fix it up.
Dave, could you gather some materials for me?
What do you need?
and we'll need some vines.
You can get vines from the lake, and for wood, we'll need
some tools.
Carpentry tools aren't exactly something I could bring on
the ship.
If there's someone in the village who could do carpentry
work, they might be able to help.
Umineko would be great since not many people experience the
full story unlike Higurashi.
Yeah, I'm one of them.
I've not experienced full Umineko craziness.
But honestly, I don't know how...
I don't think an audiobook would work for Umineko.
I think it has to be a visual novel.
Or in some sort of text form.
This is crazy long.
It's so long.
Can you read a word in red?
That's what I mean!
Yeah, I don't think it would work, huh?
Hmm.
Oh, not too bad.
Say it in red, Minto.
Maybe like a voice effect.
Yeah.
Also kind of intense, not exactly relaxing sleep material.
I'm not sure about that.
I could fall asleep to anything.
Take a look around the village.
Okay.
La la la la la la la la.
La la.
You do carpentry.
Mr. Oh, giving gifts.
Rimboo!
I'm not sure what kind of...
where to find gifts people would like.
Folks like all different things.
I can sell you some of the stuff I brought from the city.
That way you don't have to go looking all over the place.
Oh, okay.
Rimboo's general store.
Wait, I want to go do the animal stacking.
Cuckoo to me!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Who are you?
Oh, you do the work.
Wait, no, you said...
Wait, maybe the afternoon.
It's still morning.
I fall asleep with Minto's VODs already, but not usually
collabs, but still some have a bit yelling.
My audiobooks will not have any yelling.
If it's yelling, it'll be like...
Because that snake's yell.
Do you do carpentry work?
here?
I don't think I've seen you around.
Penneb.
I'm here to look into the strange things happening in the
village.
I'll be staying a while.
Yoroshku.
Heh, names Penneb.
I handle most of the handiwork around here.
Haven't been doing much lately, though.
Took a tumble down a hill during that earthquake.
So that's why you're wearing bandages.
Hope it heals up soon.
By the way, I need some wood.
Think you could help?
down a tree nearby.
We came here by a boat.
We didn't bring any tools.
I'd sell you some if I had any despair, but with my arm like
this, I haven't been able to swing an axe.
If you need that, I can lend you my and my axe.
The carpenters make carpet, right?
No, they make music.
Sing.
Sing a song.
You'll have to get the wood yourself.
Your axe.
Well, I've done it once or twice, but I guess that's how it
goes out here.
Thanks, I'll take good care of it and bring it back.
Animal Crossing.
Wait, I'm gonna...
No!
I'm cutting down your tree.
Is this the guy that we wanted to do the animal stacking?
Yeah, it looks like it.
I don't think I want audiobooks with John.
jump scares what would the jump scare be what would it be it
wouldn't be jump scare who are you the herbs are oh could i
ask you a favor what can i help you with i've been mixing
various herbs and i could use some more bamboo shoots could
you gather three bamboo shoots from nearby okay they should
be near bamboo you're quite sharp i'll be counting on you
okay the ghost reading it's a jump in and of itself, huh?
Wait, oh my gosh, this is such a...
We don't have to go searching everywhere.
It's such a nice little update to the game.
Or maybe it was like this before.
Can't quite remember.
What's this?
Oh.
Timber!
It's going down.
I'm yelling, Timber!
You might have moved.
dance speaking of mgs auto audiobooks again would you read
natasha romanenko's novel perspective on the shadow moses
incident i feel most of us have never read it i i would love
to if i could find a way to read it yeah these are chickens
bamboo shoots Yes, here you are.
Thank you.
This will be enough for my research.
It's not much, but please accept this as a token of my
gratitude, outsider.
Cilantro.
It's an MGS2, no?
Well, I mean, like...
Uh...
Like, I guess, a text version.
So that I don't have to have the game open while I read it,
you know what I mean?
Yeah, like a script.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And also, with a book, I can mark where I left off and stuff
for recording purposes.
Yeah, yeah.
But it is a good idea.
I think I will add that to my plans.
Yay.
Alrighty.
Oh, stick.
So we have an axe now.
Sculpture of a standing bear.
Would be scary if it were real.
What?
No, not even a little.
Who are you?
Hi there.
I'm Uncle Dave.
Whoa.
You're an outsider?
They say outsiders pluck out people's eyeballs and eat them
like candy.
Is that true?
During the streams with no model, I kept looking at my
phone, thinking my phone was zoomed in.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I couldn't be there.
What kind of nonsense is that?
Where'd you hear that?
Beema told me.
I'm glad it's not true.
I'm Sonia.
My brother is Eka.
I see.
I'll be staying here for a while, so let's get along.
Cute.
Cannibalism mentioned?
Question mark?
Maybe?
Maybe.
Oh, wait.
Were we able to upgrade?
Yes, now we can upgrade our purification thing.
Equipment enhance.
There goes all my money.
Wait, actually, what's the next one?
Vertebra.
Two hours plus alpha cannibalism.
How do I upgrade my jungle gun?
Oh, it's just...
It's just cash.
Dang it.
Okay.
Oh, we need...
We need the wood, too.
To fix my house, huh?
Let's see.
Where can we cut down a tree?
Oh!
Bananas?
Whoa!
Banana rank three!
Vertebrate.
Bruh.
Banana flower.
Wait, what are you?
Oh, oh, more leaves.
Banana leaf.
Oh my gosh.
It's the giving tree for real.
That book always made me mad.
I...
Oh my you must be the outsider who came to study the
dinosaurs nice to meet you I'm lipa hello.
I'm Dave.
It might be a little quiet for some from the city But this
village has so many beautiful insects that alone makes me
feel like heaven to me Same right it's so bad.
It's so mean
Made me feel sad for the tree it made me feel sad for the
tree and then They get mad at the tree.
I could see why.
I haven't seen anything like this in the city.
It's nice to meet someone who understands.
I look forward to working with you.
Likewise.
Where's a dang tree I can cut down?
You?
Deforeasing the village.
I like how he was just like, yeah, just take anything around
the...
Just cut down any trees around here.
They don't matter to us, apparently.
It's dangerous to just head out.
I should ask Rimbo.
Never mind.
Rimbo.
There's a lot of people to talk to.
Well, we can talk to them later.
tree oh my gosh eggs what oh my gosh huge who's playing oh
this guy nice to meet you I'm Dave staying in this village
for a while I was just about to have a brilliant musical
idea adults oh really sorry I misclicked really have no
respect oh right sorry about that he hates me he hates me
everybody King Oyster Mushroom.
That is a mouthful, huh?
This village is huge.
He's an artiste, and I am not respecting his craft.
So many eggs.
Wait, is this a tree that we need to cut down?
Yeah.
Nice.
Now we have enough.
Alright, we'll talk to him next time.
we are gonna go back into the water wait just kidding we're
good we are about to wait is afternoon how that would be
evening no the next time let's let's go see if this guy's
around i should hurry if i want to get into the lake okay
stop backseating me dave oh he is here he is here he is you
made it want to try that animal block stacking yeah yeah
yeah that's my kind of simple we take turns stacking these
animal blocks and whoever knocks them over first loses dave
the bagseater best way to learn try yourself let's get
started okay yeah i'm excited for this
okay what the hell uh the proboscis monkey fall
nimi nightmare she'll never betray me nimi nightmare
Nightmare!
You'll never betray me!
This is pretty fun!
Glad to hear it, pal.
Plenty of folks around here love this game, too.
Win a match and I'll give you a new animal block.
Bring me three of them and I'll have a little something for
you.
Wait, can I play again?
30 money!
Okay, wait a second.
I don't even have that much.
I don't even have that much money.
Okay, let's get out of here.
Kapo!
really gifted.
Demi.
Look at the frogs!
Oh my gosh, so cute.
Alright.
Dave the backseater over here.
If we did just upgrade our thing, though, I'm excited.
It wasn't Jenga, though.
I thought it seemed more like...
It seemed like...
a strange Suika game.
Oh, what's in here?
Grumble, grumble!
Thank you for 24 months!
Thank you so much!
Oh, God, the piranha.
Oh, boy, the piranha.
Let's be careful.
Who's that guy?
He's going crazy in not-so mode.
Oh.
Oh, it's a blue gill.
Salantro.
There's so much salantro.
We should get, catch some more stuff though, because I did
run out.
Oops.
And I have so much space for stuff, like we'll be totally
fine.
We should buy, or should get some stuff.
While we're down here, some normal fishies.
Ah, yes!
Nice.
The chocolate gourami!
What if it's... Oh no, no, no, no, no.
I don't think I'm ready.
Actually, let me try.
Now go!
Ouch,
ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh,
I got him.
Yeah, Bozo.
Nice.
Nice, nice, naisu!
What is this?
Oh, big guy, big guy, big guy.
Switch to my gun, just in case.
Oi!
Is this a friend?
Yes?
What is that?
Oh, that's a powerful guy.
He's purple.
He's really big.
But I need to go down there.
Ah!
I'm so... Oh, it's over for me?
It's over for me.
Can I get you?
Ah!
Oh, jeez!
Stop!
Leave me alone!
Wait, now I can go grab this.
Dinosaur school!
We got it.
Disco.
We got a pattern stone tablet.
He's still after me.
He hates me.
Oxygen.
Whew, foo, foo, foo.
Start shooting.
I think it's too powerful for me right now.
What is this right here though?
Pottery artifact.
So we're supposed to find things and take pictures, it
seems?
Gosh, it's stanky down here.
Oh, here's one, here's one.
Yes.
This must be one of the stone tablets.
She said there'd be three.
Let's take a photo of this one first.
Yeah.
Wait, what are you?
What are you?
You look delicious.
A mud carp, I retract my statement.
How do I take a photo of it?
Oh, here we go.
There we go.
Here we go.
And...
Tease!
Oh,
nice!
Are those sea people holding spears?
Don't tell me there were sea people here, too?
But their outfits are different from the sea people I've
seen.
They look more menacing, too.
What was that supposed to mean?
Wait, that guy's a bad guy.
Baddy, baddy, baddy.
Yeah.
snake head.
Sick.
What are you?
Oh, okay.
Wait, I can get you.
I can get you.
Come on, come on, come on.
Come on.
Don't be, don't be like that, baby.
Don't be like that, baby girl.
Come on, girl.
Come on, come on, come on.
Don't be like that.
No, no, no, no.
Come on, come on.
I'm almost out of oxygen.
I'm gonna die without you.
Come on, girl.
That's like a brand.
I'm a fan of that.
There's like, there's like a J-fashion brand called Nile
Perch.
Wait, that's so funny.
She went running away from me.
I know.
Large mouth bass.
But not good quality because I kind of, I'll beat her up.
No, the outfits are like baby clothes.
I'm not even kidding.
Wait, why are you so powerful?
What are you?
Horse face ludge.
That's not very nice.
Uh oh.
Wait, I'm in trouble.
Wait, I'm in trouble for real.
What the heck is that?
Uh oh.
I'm in trouble for real.
Okay.
Ooh, that was close.
Did you guys see that?
There was a big guy.
Oh!
Whoa!
That's a huge black Cayman.
Seeing it underwater is terrifying.
Those jaws clamp down on me I'm done for.
Wait, it doesn't see me, right?
This thing is massive.
That can't be where the other thing is.
That can't be where the other stone is, right?
That'd be insane.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh, oops.
Yeah.
Get his butt.
Get his butt!
Yeah.
Let's get some more fish before we go up.
I have so much oxygen.
We can just, like, fish guys for the menu.
Yeah.
Come here, Discuses.
I can't remember which is the one that we put on the menu
that like sold out.
It was pretty popular.
What if it was just tilapia?
I don't think I got a single tilapia, actually.
I want to see that guy.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, water chestnut!
Oh, yummy!
Yummy, yummy!
Ooh, okay.
Was it the chocolate one?
What are you?
This guy looks nice.
you.
A kissing grubby!
That's lured.
Echee.
Oh my god.
I see.
I'm sorry.
My big head is blocking him.
He looked bigger in the cutscene.
Kissing fish.
Cow.
No!
Let's go find... I think I'm trapped in here, unfortunately.
Because I have to go back down, you know.
Into the hazards.
Oh, kissing.
Not kissing.
Chocolate.
Chocolate, chocolate.
Yeah, I can go up.
But I didn't want to necessarily...
Oopsie.
I didn't really want to leave just yet.
These fish, like, trust me so much.
I am running out of...
I am, uh...
What's it called?
I have a lot of inventory, so we can leave soon-ish.
Nah, we'll just leave now.
Who is a better kisser than Goramis or the...
What?
What the squire?
Squire...
Ah!
Or a squail!
Let's spell it properly.
Those guys.
Those guys were the better kissers.
A squail, of course.
A squail.
Oh, it's about time.
Aw, man, already?
Mom, I don't want to get it.
Mom, I want to keep swimming.
What are you?
Are these coconuts for us?
The outsiders of the place.
Oh, this is it.
That place the outsiders running.
You're the farmer who supplies with coconuts and papayas?
That's right.
Name's Jepun.
I run the farm up north.
Don't know what you're here for, but you're probably here to
tell us what we're missing compared to the city.
Oh.
You're probably here to tell us what we're missing compared
to the city.
Then leave.
Oh.
Oh, like there's...
gonna tell okay i thought it was like him saying like if
you're gonna tell us what we're missing then leave but no
that's not my intention at all the chief asked so i'll
deliver the crops just stay out of my way and you'd better
appreciate the premium coconuts grill them with my own blood
and sweat this guy's got many concussions i want to keep
kissing those grommies he's pretty hostile just as the chief
said some villagers are wary of outsiders Guess not every
outsider treats people here with respect.
Still, if we help them with what they need, we might be able
to bridge the gap.
He's got freaky eyes like a cat.
Him?
You better not tell me what I'm missing.
You better not tell me what I'm missing from the city.
Okay, our menu.
We add Oh, I have so much Guerrilla Discus.
Let's actually Enhance it.
Is it the same as the bird?
The parrot one?
Maybe it's different.
Yeah, I think it's different.
Oh, now we're a panther.
Oh!
We're pouncing.
And placing.
Oh, is it?
so silly it's so awesome and so silly all right and uh auto
supply that baby brown discus what did i oh wait we leveled
up something i guess i don't oh it was the tilapia i knew it
we can also enhance our Gorami.
Awaken the anamorph.
And then the brown discus will also enhance it.
I wonder if we're inspired by anything.
Oh, we are!
We are!
Fried egg!
We're researching?
I want to try bonchos cooking.
It's not fair.
of flower salad sounds awesome right whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa
fried egg let's just let's just unlock everything y'all nice
okay and then maybe we can add monkey tier or higher Yeah,
um...
Can I even add some of these?
Not really, so we'll just stick with the fish then.
Alright, open up, baby!
Check out what we got.
What do you want?
You're reading?
I'm hungry after that workout.
Of course she's here first, right?
Was Mia's her name, right?
Yes, indeed.
It's so good, I moved!
Rambu!
What do you want?
Oh, a drink?
Oh.
Oops, I messed it up a little bit.
I still got a good.
It's fine.
He's sipping.
Sippy sip, sip, sip, sip.
I want to eat it all.
All right.
Two of the same thing.
Very nice.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Let me grab it.
Please, thank you.
Okay.
The food is not running late.
You just ordered it.
For real.
It's dinner time for me too, I think.
Oh, he's ordering a second one?
Holy cow.
We're going to give it to her first, though.
It should be coming out by now.
It is.
In two seconds.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't be upset.
They really have no chance.
like actually I know.
Oh no!
Snake better say love can bloom in the restaurant.
He would?
Nobody ever gets the, whatever that salad looking thing is.
It's the same people as before.
I made friends but none of them can.
Sad.
My friends hate us.
Reminds me of Toho Mistia's Izakaya.
I want to play the...
Salas for when you run out of food.
Oh, that makes sense.
I hear some kind of loud noise.
Sounds like it's coming from the upper part of the village.
I should go check it out.
This late?
No way.
Oh my gosh, they're looking for aliens.
Have you seen anything glowing in the sky around here?
Not that I've seen.
It has to be here.
My UFO radar is pointing straight at this village.
Excuse me, would it be okay if we stayed in this village for
a while?
We came all this way.
We can't leave without finding any trace of the UFO.
I'm not really the one who can give you permission.
But the lake beach should be fine.
Why don't you stay over there?
Thank you.
Aliens, you need rank two or three per villager.
No way, really?
Okay.
Everyone, let's rest up and search again tomorrow.
In the name of the Shimano University Mystery Research Club,
we'll find that UFO.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Oh, man, we got, like, the real Otaku in here.
Animal block stacking showdown quest.
Wait, let me go talk to Cobra.
See if he'll fix my house for me tonight.
Wait, what's up?
They all flew away.
What's wrong?
The fireflies I kept in a jar for light at home.
They all escaped.
Ma'am, I hate to tell you, but they would be dead in like
hours if you kept all your ladybug...
Not ladybug, sorry.
Your fireflies in a jar.
I had them instead of lanterns so the lizards wouldn't be
uncomfortable at night.
Wait, I love her?
anything i can help with i tried catching them again but
it's not going well could you catch three fireflies for me
you would not believe your eyes if you caught three
fireflies my house is full of lizards but i don't have
anything to catch them with all right then a bug net it's
just turning more and more into animal crossing this should
work leave it to me
Bug nut.
Wait, how do I use this thing?
I skipped a tutorial.
Wait.
Firefly!
You would not believe your eyes.
Fire!
Can we add these to our dish?
To our restaurant?
wait i can give her something i'm gonna give her a pink
evening of primrose oh my pink evening primrose i've
actually been interested in things like this lately thank
you dave we're so in we're in we're in we're in we're in
we're in if you want to play mischie's it's on sale for
three bucks at the moment and version 4.4 released two
months ago so it's It's so chill and lovely.
Wait, that sounds awesome.
What are your favorite things?
I prefer meat over fish.
Meat is always the answer.
So you like it too, Dave?
I used to catch a lot of wild animals in the forest, but I
haven't been able to eat much since the path was blocked.
I really miss it sometimes.
Interesting.
She likes some meat, huh?
Oh.
Here's your fireflies.
Thank you.
Now I can have some light at night so the lizards won't be
uncomfortable.
I love that that's her reasoning.
Please keep up the good work.
Damn, she paid me for that.
Let's go.
Level up!
Woody woodpecker.
Is that what you're saying I sound like, huh?
Clam shell.
Aw, Minky's being creepy again.
Deep cut!
You're the ones...
You guys are the ones calling me a Woody woodpecker!
star fruit oh i want some fruit real bad i want some fruit i
want i want i want you know what on a hot summer day the
best thing watermelon i want a watermelon real bad i love
all your life me too even when i sound like a woodie
woodpecker even when I sound like...
Can I catch this guy now?
Oh, he loves me.
Wait, he's not leaving.
He's...
Just makes it better.
Really?
You're not just saying that, are you?
Banana leaf.
Looks...
This 100% looks like we're going to be able to mine it.
Doesn't it?
Oh.
I was gonna go talk to Cobra, but we'll just go to bed, I
guess.
I hope it doesn't rain again.
Pretty lady sells lizard food.
Shut up.
Okay, we're fine.
Let's make the most of today!
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh, it's raining a little bit, but we're okay.
That was cute.
She put on her thing.
Um, oh.
Oh, I got...
It threw me into a cutscene.
Hello?
Leipa is a lizard lady.
She's destined for you, Minto.
I think so!
Dr. Bacon, what are you taking up?
Dave, this is something called an...
I thought I said ultra crystal.
I was like, what a... what a Chuni name.
Utara crystal.
It's a unique mineral found only in this region.
I've been studying it since it might be useful for crafting
tools.
Take a look at this.
Can you feel that energy coming off of it?
There's a kind of shimmering light flowing through it.
It's a fascinating material.
The Matara crystal.
It's even her color.
The only issue is you can only extract a small amount from
each crystal.
I could use your help with that.
How can I help?
Be able to find solidified Matara crystals scattered across
the village and the lake.
Bring me seven of them?
You better maybe some good at tools, mister.
I was just wishing I had some of Cobra's tools.
Perfect timing.
I'll collect them when I come across.
Okay.
The Matara crystal.
I do want to go swim swamming.
Oh, look at this little guy!
Ah!
I got a snail.
I need
more snails.
Oh, Matara Crystal.
Excuse me.
All right.
Making my way.
Making my way downtown.
Walking fast.
Chickens all over.
Bacock, bacock, bacock, bacock.
No, no, bacock, bacock, bacock.
I think I saw one of those crystals on Craigslist.
What does that mean?
Wait, is that a reference?
Oh, yeah.
Give me some more eggies.
You little chickens.
Actually, they're...
Oh, no.
Yeah, little chickens here.
Stinking chickens.
Let's grab more of these, too, huh?
Oh.
This Joe Crystal.
What is that?
Why is it on Craigslist?
Oh, here's one.
Oh my gosh, I would have missed it.
It was hiding, though.
No, not the wooden bell.
It is a really big bell, though.
Don't worry about it.
Why am I not supposed to worry?
internet lore.
Whoa!
I have no idea.
I am but a ghost.
Is this thing gonna decay?
I guess actually it is decaying, isn't it?
It looks terrible.
Come on, animals!
Eat up!
Oh, they really did make a shop here.
Like, they built themselves the tiniest tent ever.
Let's give her a gift.
She probably likes something to read, right?
Is this...
Can I give the ancient pattern stone tablet?
Because I feel like I might need that later.
It must smell as bad as it looks.
I agree.
I'm scared of ghosts.
what is there to be scared of actually though oh my gosh my
mom has been scaring me oh my god let me read you the text
she sent me
my mom texted me the other night she said I had the
strangest thing happen I said good night to my nieces and
turned around to walk into my room and I swear I saw grandma
looking at me from my tall dresser and my I used to wear
like a certain headband and it said she had that headband
around her head She looked like snake actually no she looked
like the boss She had that headband around her head that she
always wore and then vanished When I came into the room her
picture from my visit with her on the last day she passed
was on my Electronic frame wow and then she sent me another
text the other day And she just goes grandma's at it again
called the Ghost Whisperer.
An old fictional series that I never heard of and found
recently about a woman who can see spirits before they pass
on into the light.
Anyway, tonight's episode was about a daughter, a mother,
and a grandmother who all share this gift.
Soon as the show is over, I turned it off and walked into
the kitchen and the light sensors and the plugs that only go
on when the lights are out were on with the lights on and
they were flashing.
First one and then the others across the room and remembered
grandma's words remember that thing my dad used to do with
the lights my dad used to like flicker the lights in my in
my mom's house uh remember that thing that my dad used to do
with the lights i'm gonna come back and do that too she's
here why would you text me that so late at night mom that
scares me and then she sent a video too of like the
flickering lights Stop!
Remember Shimbuff, they come up behind me.
No Speratu.
Somehow that sounds exactly like what your grandma would do.
Yeah, my grandma was a mischievous type, so...
Grandma's at it again!
How can a ghost be haunted by another ghost?
So freaky, though, right?
grandma don't do that shit to me i'll pee my pants actually
she would find that funny too a yellow evening primrose
thank you for thinking of me dave ah she liked it
it's nice to have some light conversation what's your
favorite things been hard to get novels here in the village
i had a feeling she would say books
go for it grandma oh yes i really love this village but
there's nothing better than novels for experiencing other
worlds i don't really read anything besides comics aren't
comics more fun dave hold on let me fix my mic real quick
there we go i didn't want to move it around and you guys
hear all the mumblings of it only text only stimulates the
imagination more with pictures there's less room to imagine
come to think of it you're always writing something do you
write novels yourself oh no i'm not skilled enough to write
novels i just dropped i just jot down my feelings in a book.
I bet Kina would love if I gave her some novels or writing
supplies.
Oh, they're out.
They're out and about.
Oh, they're checking.
They're ignoring the dinosaur and instead looking only for
only for aliens.
They're looking up in the sky.
They can't see what's at their very feet.
Thank you again for catching those fireflies for me.
Don't mention it.
I even got a bug net out of it.
Thanks to them.
I can light up my room at night so my lizards don't get
scared.
Looks like Lippa really loves lizards.
She's the best.
Wait.
Oh no, she can't give me the lizard food that you guys
mentioned.
Lizards in my room!
I will have every lizard on this one they will come to me
all right let's go diving baby
lost in the store thank you so much for the 20 gifts thank
you hot lizards in your area
what if she is a lizard lady like legitimately like not even
just like oh she likes lizards she just is a lizard that
would be even cooler That'd be so awesome.
So we're looking for two more photo spots.
And also tilapia.
Oh!
Did you see that?
They were kissing.
They were kissing in public.
They were the kissing guys!
What were they called?
The kissing...
Oops.
Just a little out of reach.
Just a little out of...
There we go.
How shameless.
You know, I never realized that, like, grabbing butts was,
like, an acceptable...
Is it acceptable?
It's a very common occurrence, I feel, like, with couples.
Does anyone else see it?
People just always grabbing butts.
No?
I always see people grabbing butts.
butts.
Well, it must be accepted, they must feel validated,
accepted to grab butts if they always are doing it, right?
What is this guy?
Oh, I guess there was something there, but I guess there was
not.
They're kissing again.
Here, I won't let you be alone.
What's this about grabbing butts?
I just see people, I see people grabbing butts all the time.
This isn't not acceptable.
Oh, the gang is here.
The gang is here.
Oh, now you don't want to give up.
I see it really often.
Like, I'm not even kidding.
People, usually people try.
Like, last time I was at the airport, I saw a guy grabbing
his lady's butt, like going down the escalator.
And I was like, Why am I always seeing people getting their
butt grabbed?
Oh, this thing's good.
I like it.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, oh, no.
Ouch!
Oh, I killed them.
Nice.
It's my special talent.
I don't wish this upon anybody, to be honest.
I don't want to be able to see people grabbing butts
anymore.
this anymore oh nice we gave them we got them all it's like
x-ray vision
hey what is this giant catfish wait i want him in the photo
i think we could get him he's not gonna get me is he dang it
oh i think it restart restart come back come back come back
thing it whatever
Broken stone.
Oh, I need to zoom out.
Are you sure you're not biased to witnessing the grabbing
because of your lower perspective?
I mean, it could be that.
But I also think people just need to be more careful if
they're grabbing butts in public.
Because I'm always watching.
And it's not that I'm watching the butts.
It's that I just look down naturally as I am walking.
This one's depicting someone diving.
So the ancient Sunan people really did deep dive into the
lake.
What is this thing, though?
Oh, stone tab, stone face tablet.
Freaky.
What is this thing?
Drift wood.
We're not gonna...
We're just gonna ignore that thing?
Okay, understandable.
It's not important, I guess.
What is this?
Always watch.
Indonesian Tiger Perch.
Cool.
Don't get me.
Okay, then.
Just something I've noticed.
People really out here be grabbing butts all the time.
Here.
This is Driftwood, but what's this guy over here?
Pottery fragment.
I did get a decent amount of tilapia, I think.
We got a few of them, so...
I want to go see this guy over here, though.
The giant catfish.
Always watch it, Wizowski.
It's your passive freaky aura influence.
I don't want this anymore.
I don't want this power.
It's not cool.
It's kind of lame.
Kind of lame though.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Ah, he is evil!
Oh god!
Acu!
I'm trying to get out of here.
Oh my god, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm dead,
I'm dead.
Oh my god, he's stupid!
He's stupid!
He's stupid because he's a fish!
That was scary.
That was a close call.
Holy cow!
Yeah, we got 10 pieces of tilapia.
Nice.
We could go back down again.
Why not?
That feels more of a shark than a cabbage.
I didn't think cabbage were so aggressive.
Am I?
Not knowing catfish?
Is this a tilapia?
Oh, oops.
We're going to have another customer today, so.
Catfish are aggressive.
No way.
I had no idea.
I'm going to go over further to the right.
Whoa.
The light was flickering all funny like.
Oh, let's do it again.
Bam, bam, bam.
Wait, is that lightning, maybe?
Ah!
Ouch!
Gosh, they kill me every time.
Stop it!
Leave me alone, you dumbfish.
Passive, aggressive.
I have to use this.
Alright.
Hi, Mindo.
Hello!
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Coconut milk!
That one's new, yeah.
You.
Oops.
One thing I forgot to mention, I forgot to say, is I did
make...
Oh shoot, ouch.
I did...
I think I made an enemy.
Ah!
With a bird in my new cafe.
I think I made enemies with a bird!
Look at him.
Where are you trying?
That's where I was going.
Oh shoot!
Ouch!
The first of many.
I hope it isn't a crow.
No, luckily it's not.
Oh, there it is.
The pearl.
Yeah, I wanted that.
Luckily it's not a crow, but it is...
He'll just like sit outside my window and be like...
I want to make a friend with a crow though.
I want to try one day.
Has anyone ever successfully...
What are these things, you know?
I keep seeing them.
Is this where the alligator is?
No, we got another thing though.
Wait, this is the one that I already took a picture of.
What the hell are you then?
Gotta find something shiny.
Something to really...
Yeah, get their interest, right?
Mud Clarp.
Oh!
No, he's so scary.
What does this one do?
Holy cat.
Oh, oh!
Cute!
I gotta get out of here.
Oh, this is the sniper.
I remember him now.
Am I trapped in here?
Shoot.
Uh, I might be dead.
That was the net.
Yeah, we're just gonna leave.
don't think there's anything interesting until the next day
yeah that's fine that's fine that's fine just got back from
a fishing trip we caught a few catfish none that big though
i'm gonna one up you you're two for two on bird sitcom arch
arch nemesis toki i guess so baby oh cute when it it off oh
thinking i was about to go give the stuff for the that's
okay that's a okay terror off the tape you gotta practice
with the gun if you want to kill the big fish i gotta
upgrade my guns if i want to kill the big fish that's why i
haven't been working on it it's fine we'll we'll get to it
we'll get to it all right it's a piranha wait
What's my level 2 stuff?
It's level 2 tilapia.
Yes, baby.
Wait, maybe I should enhance it, though.
Yeah, we can totally.
Oh, now we're an elephant!
Sometimes birds make nests inside your house.
It's amazing when the babies hatch.
Next, you'll hear, like, chirping on the...
I'm on stream, I'll be like, sorry, but that's just my
babies, my baby birds.
Wee!
We are elephants.
So, I trust me!
Delicious level 3 tilapia.
Oh, whoops, a menu.
Let's also add some of the discus.
And let's add...
Oh,
fish sauce is more what I need.
Okay.
Oh, it also tells you where to get it.
That's so nice.
I don't want to do a recipe with tilapia.
We'll do the chocolate gourami, because I have a lot of
those right now.
Same menu as before, but people seem to like it, so...
Who cares?
Oh, wait.
there was stuff I could research.
He's researching on the job.
Whoa!
Yes!
Steam tricolor discus.
Dang, this is really yummy.
Sparrows make their nests in the eaves of my back porch
every year in the baby sparrows hatch there.
two different families of sparrows who hate each other do it
do it and get into fights wait that's crazy wait maybe i
should change the menu wait swap for the thing that we just
made just kidding we don't have a brown discus okay we gotta
get the hello chief Sparrow gang wars.
That's crazy.
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
Perfect!
What should I eat?
I'm here.
They're so far away.
Like, the dishes and stuff, you know.
This is the stuff.
Oh, my girl is here.
Yes!
What can I get for you, my queen?
There she is.
Yes!
She thinks it's so delicious.
It is!
With love, specifically for you!
For you!
Tell the lizards I said hello!
Time to Riz.
Did she tip well?
She means she's into me?
Maybe?
guy always orders two things though.
Hey, where are you?
Where have you been?
Oh, you're going over there.
Dave is full of love here.
I want to eat it all, he says.
Another.
You're starting to get hungry.
It's, it's, it's on the plate being delivered.
That stirred something inside me.
Literally that sparrow thing was the same as the squirrels,
but like that video, well not the video, but the screenshot
of them kissing.
They live in a box and they own it, they're like, this is
our box.
And if other squirrels come in, they're like, no.
Girl just ate and yet she's still thirsty.
Why did they avoid the middle table?
Maybe it's smelly there, who knows?
Nice!
that screenshot again wait i think it's on my other computer
wait hold on
oh it's on my other no wait it's right here
it's right there
eyes wide open
ah it's so funny
Steiner complained about this one I don't care what he has
to say ever The top squirrel is so into it It's like It
feels like an art piece No like it feels like a renaissance
painting Where it's like two Two people passionately making
out And then what another squirrel in the back on watch I
want what they have It's so It's so like art.
It's so
it's so amazing.
It is very passionate.
It's awesome.
This is how squirrels apparently greet each other.
Oh, something.
Oh, sorry.
He mentioned something about the UFOs.
Early like my first kiss.
Damn.
Don't tell me there's something actually, something there.
I think it headed up the hill on the right side of the
village.
I should go check it out.
The music.
Ooh.
Hey, can I just find anything?
Oh, sir, keep your voice down.
I've got a good feeling about today.
All right, go at it.
But weren't there three of you before?
He asked, though.
He got bitten by a wild spider on the way here and came down
with a high fever.
He won't be able to join today's expedition.
I see.
So you're using that telescope to look for you.
I don't care about your friend at all that got bit by a
poisonous spider and is probably dying in bed because,
Whatever.
He's gonna be Spider-Man!
He's in bed right now, being like, they're looking for UFOs.
Shouldn't somebody be watching him if he has a high fever?
They're gonna go back down to him and he's gonna be like,
guys, I saw the aliens.
They came in.
They offered me food.
Do you want to try?
And he's gonna hand them the...
That whale meat, the beached whale meat.
I ate it.
It was delicious.
It made me five times stronger.
So you're using that telescope.
That's right.
I, Fukuoka, in the name of Shimano University Research Club,
will prove the existence of UFOs today.
You're with me on this, right?
Takeru?
Takeru, Kun?
Takeru, do no?
Ayaisa.
Ah, so.
Sir Yasuto's telecamera.
Could you handle it for us?
Me?
Yes, sir.
We can't let Yasuto's sacrifice be in vain.
All right, could you tell me what I need to do?
I'll show you.
First, go to the telecamera and look up at the sky.
Traces of the UFO!
Hold on, let me grab this real quick.
Who are we sacrificing?
Yasuto.
He's a goner.
Whoa!
A glowing object!
What is that?
Sir, take a photo.
So Yasuto's soul can cherish the moment.
Yasuto's still alive, though.
They already have given up on Yasuto.
Oh, uh...
Capture with Mac Zoom.
Okay, I can retake it.
I can retake it.
Nice.
Yeah, why is so bright?
It looks like actually somebody on like a jetpack.
Like the ones in Metal Gear.
Excellent, that's a great shot.
But one photo might look fake.
Take another.
Oh, okay, it's faster now.
Wait, did it?
No, why did you get rid of my zoom?
No!
Restart.
Nice.
Did you see it?
Perfect, but I feel like it's getting closer.
Maybe it just came out clearer.
One more shot and we'll know for sure.
What is this thing?
This is going on the subreddit.
Oh, come on.
That one had a good one.
That was good.
Wow!
Outer Wild!
It definitely looks bigger than before!
It's really getting bigger.
So, sir, it's headed straight for us.
Wow.
Outer wilds, outer wilds, outer wilds.
Wow!
Is everyone okay?
Thank goodness it missed us.
Fuku-o, don't tell me...
Oh, no, Fuku-o-o-dono.
Don't tell me you used that sealed psychokinetic energy to
save us.
Who knows?
Maybe I sense the danger, and it just...
Slipped out.
I saw.
Right now, we should go after the crushed UFO first.
You're so calm even in a situation like this, Foucault.
That's real leadership.
I can't believe there was actually a UFO!
Judging by the direction it fell, probably near the lake
beach.
Let's go check it out.
He's an Esper.
He's so cool.
Wait, I want to be friends with these guys for real.
There's nothing imaginary about his friends.
technique, leave him alone.
I didn't say anything.
Whoa, is that really a spaceship?
Told you, sir.
We picked up a signal here.
Our long investigation has finally paid off.
Shimano... Wait, I can't remember the... Shimano University
Mystery Research Club made me shine forever.
I can't remember the voices I'm giving these 10 characters.
I think Alien life form.
Kind of feel attacked by these characters, it's too real.
It's an old man.
It's actually an old man.
Lan, thank you so much for watching!
Thank you.
A middle-aged man!
Martin Tweed.
Where am I?
This is Matara Village.
You're in the giant...
Welcome to the jungle!
More importantly, is this Earth?
Thank you, Lance!
Thank you so much!
What the heck!
I'll for a few months focused on work, but we'll try to
catch up with VODs when I can.
I wasn't here for the start of stream, but I hope you have
things set up at the new maid cafe.
Also, Dave DLC looks fine.
Thank you so much!
Good luck with work!
What the heck?
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
You are an alien.
Two eyes, one mouth.
You copied the human form.
But the hair, you only got it half right.
What's this guy talking about?
What's this dude he happened about?
He's calling you bald, Mr. Tweed!
I'm the CEO of Kindred Aerospace, Martin Tweed.
Kindred is the world's fourth...
largest spacecraft manufacturer you've heard of us right I
have I have even now here we're known our marketing team's
doing great by the way the signal here isn't great I was
testing a prototype spacecraft and the GPS got scrambled
those engineers can't believe they missed that it'll take a
while for my rescue signals wait did this crash into their
tent Yasuto Yasuto!
It'll take a while for my rescue signal to reach HQ.
I'll be staying in this village until then.
Not an alien after all.
I'm disappointed.
If he came from space, does that still make him an alien?
Well, aliens usually have, you know, big air.
Big, big eyes, no hair.
Not big hair.
In that sense, maybe he kind of counts.
Anyway, we should head back and discuss this properly.
Let's call it a day, Takeru Dodo.
Traces of the UFO.
What a funny group, huh?
Oh my god, Yasuto!
Oh wait.
Never mind, I think he's fine.
Oh, are you okay?
He's dead!
There's- oh my god!
the stench is awful it's rotting oh my gosh couldn't they
like at least try to push it in or something for a gift wait
she likes if you want a stone face
i hope you'll come to appreciate the beauty of life in this
village dave i've appreciated the beauty all right research
equipment better not touch anything okay well guys i think
i'm gonna call it here
uh how do i save save and return to title oh there we go
that works i think i'm gonna i'm gonna call it here that was
a lot of fun what a fun dlc we could pick it up another time
Hmm.
Thank you guys.
Thank you so, so much.
I'm going to go eat dinner because I'm so hungry.
Hungry, hungry.
Sketty is waiting for me.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you.
Oh, great return to the usual setup.
Yeah, and I didn't seem to have any issues.
So I think I can...
The only thing is I haven't yet set up my capture card.
So I would like to do deadly premonition, but I got to get
all that hooked up.
so that I can capture my switch again.
I haven't even set up my switch.
It's just kind of, it's, it's, it's somewhere.
But, um, yay!
Yippee, yippee!
Thank you guys so, so much for, um, for joining me for Dave
the Diver DLC.
We'll do it again.
Maybe it's sometime later this week.
I don't know.
I don't know how long it's supposed to be, but I'd like to
get through it.
Oh, sorry.
Thank you for the stream, just letting you know Godzilla and
Yakuza DLCs are going to be delisted at the end.
the year in case you oh thank you yes thank you thank you i
do i do oh griffin thank you so much for the raid we were
just ending oh shoot maybe there's somebody else we can raid
into instead let me see uh
when is is vicky feby uh
Thank you, Fabry.
I do not see.
Thank you, Minto.
Happy Skiy.
Thank you.
Thank you, Rust and Glitch Face.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Henya.
I wonder, sometimes I can't.
Sometimes some people don't have raids set up.
So let me see if it'll let me raid into her.
Henya.
No, she doesn't have a set up.
Well, shoot.
Well, um...
You guys just have a great, wonderful evening then, or day,
or whatever, whatever.
So, thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will see you when I see you next.
Oh, thank you, guys.
Thank you, guys.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye,
bye-bye, bye-bye.
Thank you, Lance.
Thank you.
Have a good dinner.
Oh, lizards.
Look at, he's back.
The, the, the, the, the, our first lizard.
But next time, well, I don't know about next time.
Whenever I am able to, whenever I am able to set it up,
lizards will be, be here.
Lizards will be added to the screen.
It will happen.
Yeah.